Herr Ahrens bitte!
Ich bin da.
Auf die 2 bitte.
Ja und wo ist bitte der Einsatz?
Ne, ich muss erstmal so ein C64, das ist nicht so schnell.
Wie heißen Sie eigentlich? Mein Name ist Hase. Erwin Lottemann. Lindemann.
Ich mach mit dem Papst eine Modeboutique in Wuppertal.
Ich eröffne mit Steve Jobs eine C64-Vintage-Game-Bibliothek. Dennis hat die letzten zwei Wochen ganz kreativ verbracht und hat Lode Runner gespielt. Warum eigentlich, Dennis?
Wollte ich schon immer wieder zocken.
Wie lange hast du denn das jetzt nicht mehr gespielt?
25 Jahre.
Das ist nicht dein Ernst.
Doch.
Du hast 25 Jahre nicht Lode Runner gespielt und warum musst du das jetzt ausgerichtet damit anfangen?
Ich glaube, jetzt haben wir ihn gerade verloren.
Warte, jetzt bin ich gestorben. Na, beim letzten Mal habe ich erzählt, ich wollte eigentlich Windows XP installieren. Also unsere Profi-Hörer, die hören ja zu, hier per, wie heißt das Ding jetzt hier? Twitter. Und das hat alles vorne und hinten nicht, also Windows macht mir nichts. Es war schon immer so, es wird wahrscheinlich immer so bleiben. Und Halo 2 wollte ich zocken, das gibt es halt nur für XP oder für Windows. Hat alles nicht geklappt. Und irgendwann, ich weiß nicht wieso, ist irgendwie so ein Keyword gefallen. Ich weiß jetzt den Anlass nicht mehr. Jedenfalls hat es damit mir ein Pling gemacht und mir fiel irgendwie Lojone ein. Und dann dachte ich, ich probiere es mal wieder. Weil ich habe es schon mal probiert, aber es war irgendwie elendig.
Und diesmal war es besser.
War es besser? Also am Anfang war es voll schlimm. Ich habe irgendwie diesen Power 64 C64-Emulator probiert. Der ging auch ganz gut, aber den darf man nur zehn Minuten spielen und dann braucht man einen Key. Voll blöd.
Qualitätssoftware?
Und dann habe ich noch Frodo probiert, das war auch Müll. Das ging irgendwie alles nicht. Und dann habe ich den Weiß C64-Emulator gefunden und der funktioniert total voll super. Und dann habe ich mir noch irgendwie...
Der ist open source.
Der ist open source. Den gibt es für Amiga, BOS, Unix, mit GTK-Zeugs und für OS X und all sowas. Müsste aber performance-mäßig, glaube ich, sogar reichen.
Macht dein Computer jetzt schon wieder Klacker-die-klacker-die-klacker-Geräusche die ganze Zeit? Mir ist es ja egal, aber dann schwert sich ja die Leute wieder.
Genau.
Und ja, der Emulator ist jedenfalls voll gut. Und dann habe ich noch das Lockdowner-Spiel gesucht und ich muss euch sagen, es ist gar nicht so einfach. Weil von damals ist zwar schon was übrig geblieben, so von diesen Disketten, aber so die Originales, alles irgendwie zerhackt und irgendwie ein Hacker schreibt sich über den anderen drüber und dann sind halt so wie Program was broken by Tralala.
Ja.
Voll schlimm. Und da hatte ich irgendwie so gar nicht so richtig Bock drauf. Übrigens, der Typ, der damals Low Drone geknackt hat, ja ich sag's jetzt mal, weil es ist ja im Internet nachzulesen, ich hoffe, Sie werden ihn jetzt nicht nachträglich verhaften, Dante103, das ist auch der, der es damals schon halt geknackt hat.
11.03 war überhaupt die Nummer 1 auf dem C64.
Broken by 11.03 und habe ich mal ein bisschen geforscht und es gibt so eine Szene-Seite über den 64er, wo die alles auflisten, weil die machen natürlich auch gerne so ein bisschen Historie und nochmal angeben nachträglich und so.
Genau, wie hieß der nochmal?
Weiß ich nicht, aber weißt du, was er jetzt programmiert?
Ach, der ist das?
Immer noch fett am Start.
Na, wie hieß der denn noch?
Andreas, glaube ich, war es so. Man muss doch gucken, der so wie der von iCAP heisst, der ist das. Ansonsten?
Bist du dir jetzt so richtig 100% sicher?
Ziemlich.
Warte mal.
Nee.
Der ist das aber nicht.
Contact, warte hier. Doch, Alexander Klaus. Ist es der? Warte, pass auf, ich geh mal auf die...
Der hat doch dann später auch irgendwie Speeddos gemacht.
Loadrunner und 1103. Weil ich hab keinen Loadrunner gefunden. Also kein richtiges. Dann hab ich gedacht, scheiße, das kann ja mal nicht sein. Und dann hab ich halt Loadrunner und 1103 eingetippt, weil es fiel mir noch ein, dass es damals von dem geknackt wurde. Und dann hab ich tatsächlich diese Szene-Seite gefunden und dort auch das Programm zum Runterladen. Was übrigens immer noch schwer illegal ist, weil der Original-Erfinder von Loadrunner, der lizenziert Loadrunner bis heute. Es gibt eine Xbox-Version von Loadrunner.
Aber für diese 25 Jahre auf Marketplace.
Ich meine, diese Games haben alle gerade ein totales Revival. Ich meine, guckt ihr auch irgendwie Tetris und alles andere.
Tetris ist doch total modern.
Tetris ist total modern. Was ist daran modern im Vergleich zum Loadrunner?
Na, Tetris gibt es erst seit wann?
Wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall sind alle Games, die wir damals auf dem C460 hatten, kommen jetzt alle auf Mobiltelefone und andere kleine Games, die wir alle kennen.
Loadrunner gibt es auf dem iPod.
Naja, ich meine, das funktioniert ja auch wunderbar. Insofern jetzt die Steuerung okay ist, weiß nicht, keine Ahnung. Ich bin ja immer so mit dieses Auf-Ecken-Drücken und so im iPhone. Das ist ja nicht so mein Film.
Nee, meiner auch nicht.
Also ich spiele jetzt gerade auch nicht auf den Namen von 1103, aber das ist definitiv nicht dieser iCAP-Typ. Das würde mich schwer überraschen.
Bist du, also ich bin aber...
Ziemlich sicher. Weil den Namen habe ich irgendwie noch im Ohr. Wir auch immer.
Hier steht, äh, hier.
1103, weil es sein Geburtstag ist und irgendwie, he did the company Omnicron and later he developed the first good browser for the Mac iCAP. Mit Bild sogar.
Echt?
Na bei der No Name Punkt C64 Punkt.
Ja, aber iCAP als guten, als guten Browser zu bezeichnen, ist schon ein Arschloch.
Ich weiß nicht, ob der es ist, aber...
Echt?
Wäre ja total komisch, wenn das nicht passen würde, oder?
Hab ich das in falschen Erinnerungen? Na gut, wir haben wieder was gelernt. Was weiß man schon.
Und ich hab mir mal wieder iCAP runtergeladen gerade.
Na ja, ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt der große Beruf war mit dem iCAP. Das war eine ganze Zeit lang eine echte Alternative, als man nötig nur...
Es war keine Alternative, es war grundsätzlich erst mal überhaupt irgendwas, oder? Nee.
Also iCAP kam relativ spät.
Es kam spät, nein. Es gab so NetzCape und Internet...
Parallel zu WE, oder?
So in etwa, ja.
Na und NetzCape.
Das war noch zu US-9-Zeiten.
Jaja, das war noch zur tiefsten US-9-Zeiten.
Was iCAP betrifft, ist das auch irgendwie immer noch die US-9-Zeit, wenn man das so startet.
Nee, der hat das mittlerweile...
Kokoifiziert?
Also er hat auf jeden Fall die eigene Rendering Engine schon vor einer ganzen Weile aufgegeben. Und macht das jetzt auch mit WebKit. Und hat halt einen weiteren WebKit-Browser im Wesentlichen. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, was er an den tollen Features noch hat. Gibt es bestimmt irgendwas ganz Schickes. Und iCAP war früher immer unglaublich schnell und hat sich zwar theoretisch an die ganzen HTML-Dinge gehalten, an die sich sonst niemand gehalten hat, aber da sich sonst niemand dran gehalten hat, hat die auch niemand genutzt. Also man konnte schon irgendwelche Grafiken darstellen und so was. Lange, bevor man davon auch nur träumen konnte.
Auf jeden Fall, Dennis hat Spaß und...
Ich hab Spaß, ja.
Hast du denn jetzt alle Level geschafft?
Also ich bin ja, deswegen wollte ich es auch unbedingt spielen, damals bis Level 143 oder so gekommen. Und dann bin ich gestorben, weil meine Leben waren vorbei. Man kriegt pro Level ein Manneken dazu. 150 bei dem ersten.
Sieben Level vor dem Ende.
Kannst du dir vorstellen, wenn ich mich geärgert hab.
Ja und dann?
Weil vor allem, du kannst ja nicht einfach mal so... Damals gab es nicht mit Abspeichern, ich hatte nicht irgendwie so Special Zeugs, um irgendwie...
Man hat nur eins aus....
zu speichern, sondern ich hatte so einen Standard C64 mit Standard Floppy, weil die ich mir sogar ausbauen musste, weil ich hatte keine eigene. Und nochmal zocken hatte ich irgendwie nie so richtig den Nerv und weiß, hat schon Stunden gedauert. Und da musste ich erst mal aufgeben und später hatte ich dann Amiga, da gab es keinen Lowrunner und C64 war nicht mehr so. Und deswegen habe ich nie wieder gezockt. Und jetzt habe ich letzte Woche probiert, bin bis Level 132 gekommen, gleich so für den zweiten Start beim ersten und nur bis 30.
Aber da kannst du dann abspeichern?
Ich kann jetzt abspeichern und dann weiterspielen, ja. Ich könnte auch richtig schummeln, aber das mache ich nicht, weil ich will ja für mich selbst halt, ich will es ja so machen wie damals und durchzocken. Und jetzt bin ich gerade beim zweiten Versuch irgendwie bei Level 75 oder so und ich habe noch über 40 Leben. Also es sieht bisher ganz gut aus.
Ich glaube, jetzt schaffe ich es.
Und dann kann ich das Thema auch wieder zur Seite legen. Aber was richtig cool ist, weil ich habe mich ein bisschen reingelesen, es gibt eine, weil wie ich schon gesagt habe, man kriegt alle möglichen C64er Games. Es gibt auch so eine Gamebase, wo irgendwie gleich so eine riesen Datenbank für Windows ist, wo du dir alle Spiele mit Screenshots verwalten kannst, mit suchen und so. Die haben 20.600 Spiele da drin.
Lass doch mal ein paar URLs fallen.
Na, irgendwie Gamebase, warte, ich muss mal... Ich muss mal in die History fragen, so meint es. gamebase64.com Und da gibt es diese Datenbank, aber da gibt es auch die Bachelor-Spiele, kann man suchen. Aber das Original-Spiele sind nur die ganzen aufgehackten Dinger, die irgendwie zerstückelt und zerstümpelt und Intro-Trailer vorne dran und alles, was du eigentlich gar nicht haben willst. Und es gibt aber ein C64 Preservation Project, der lässt sich die Original des Ketten schicken, scannt die irgendwie mit so einem Special Nibble Copy Tool irgendwie ein, wo auch die Sync-Bits und alle von nicht die eigentlichen Daten, sondern auch noch die, nennt man so eine Bits, diese so dazwischen machen, damit es halt diese Füll-Bits, damit zu den hintereinander wechseln. Wie nennt man diese Bits, diese dann damit reinpumpen? Also bei der 1541 Floppy heißt das GCR-Encoding. Sonst gibt es noch MFM-Encoding. Ich weiß noch nicht, wie es heißt.
Ich kenne das nur von CD-ROMs, dieses Prinzip, dass wenn zu viele Nullen oder zu viele Einsentrenner kommen, weiß der Schreiblesekopf nicht mehr...
Wie viele es waren.
Wie viele es waren und darum muss man hin und wieder mal switchen. Mindestens ein, bitte.
Jedenfalls diese Füllbits, die werden bei diesem Spezial-Copy-Vorgang mit aufgenommen und die gibt es als Files und du hast sozusagen die originales Kette mit allen Fehlern, die noch unten drunter sind, auch gleich mit. Das heißt, der Kopiershots, du brauchst den gar nicht mehr entfernen in dem Emulator, sondern der wird gleich mit... also der ist auch immer noch da.
Er emuliert den Kopiershots mit.
Wenn jetzt das Lolo da fragt, ob Track 2 irgendwie okay ist, dann sagt der Emulator tatsächlich, ne, da ist irgendwie die Spur ist out of sync. Das kann er jetzt tatsächlich glatt sagen.
Verstehe. Also ich hab damals ein bisschen 1541 Hacking gemacht. Und dass man da jetzt so einen Low-Level-Access hätte, ist mir nicht bekannt, aber man konnte so einen Half-Step machen.
Half-Tracks meinste?
Genau.
Die gibt's auch noch. Und die werden auch, die können auch Half-Tracks da irgendwie mitschneiden und die gibt's dann auch in diesem Format. Das heißt Punkt G64. Also es gibt einen Loadrunner-Punkt D64-Image, das ist die Original-Diskette mit den originalen Blöcken. Und dann gibt's aber auch welche, die heißen Punkt G64, dann sind tatsächlich auch längere Tracks, Half-Tracks und alles Mögliche mitgespeichert.
Das ist sozusagen das Rohrformat, der Floppy Disk.
Genau. Und dann funktionieren auch alle Programme mit den übelsten Kopierschutzgeschichten funktionieren dann auch im Emulator. Und du kannst auch diese Images nehmen, also diese G64, um das Original wieder herzustellen. Noch nicht ganz alles. Es gibt wohl noch ein paar mega super Kopierschutze, die kannst du zumindest so sein, sodass ein 64er die wieder lesen könnte. Aber zumindest kannst du sie im Emulator spielen oder emulieren.
Der Chat fragt sich gerade, was ich meine, wenn ich sage 1541-Hacking. Sollte man vielleicht nochmal erklären, weil das weiß ja auch nicht jeder.
Das Laufwerk von...
VC 1541 ist die Modellbezeichnung des Kettenlaufwerks. Floppy Laufwerk, genau. Also es gab mal eine 1540 und dann...
Nee, 1542 war es, glaube ich.
Ich glaube, es gab auch noch eine 1540. 1541 ist so...
Es gibt ganz die Modoren-Modelle.
Aber nicht für den C64.
Das gibt es auch noch, die 1571, mit Doppelseitig und so.
Das kam später.
Ja klar, aber gibt es halt.
Da hatte ich glaube ich C64 schon wieder verlassen.
Und die für den C128 und dann gab es halt Laufwerke für die anderen Modelle, die aber teilweise kompatibel waren und all sowas.
Okay, also ich rede jetzt nur so von, als der C64 noch braun war.
Ganz dicke Latte. 1581 gab es irgendwie auch. Und die emulierende heutzutage, aber alles von vorne bis hinten, das ist total krass.
Was auf jeden Fall ganz nett war, ähm, äh, da bringst du mich ganz durcheinander, beim 1541 Hackereien, also ich hatte irgendwie mal so mir diese Data-Backgas-Software irgendwann mal so vorgenommen, weil die hatte auch nämlich auch so, die hat nämlich glaube ich das mit diesen Half-Tracks gemacht.
Was sind denn Half-Tracks?
Kann ich ganz cool erklären, ich hab mich da voll reingelesen. Also pass auf, eigentlich so ein 1541 Laufwerk hat eigentlich 82 Spuren, da der Lese-Kopf aber zu breit ist dafür, damals, also der ging mehr oder weniger über zwei Spuren drüber, haben sie immer, ähm, jede zweite Track benutzt. Und sind immer sozusagen zwei Steps weitergefahren. Deswegen kommst du sozusagen dann auf 40 Tracks von dem, die auf dem 64 oder 35 benutzt haben.
Also der Stepper-Motor konnte 80 Tracks anfahren, von denen nur die Hälfte benutzt wurde.
Genau, jetzt haben die Kopierschutz-Dinger, haben es aber so gemacht, dass die ihren Track nicht, also du musst dir vorstellen, die haben eigentlich immer jeden geraden Track benutzt. Und jetzt hast du aber einen Kopierschutz gemacht, da wurde das Kettenhersteller von so einer Spielefirma, die haben ihren Blog einfach auf einen ungeraden geschrieben. So und dann, wenn du aber nur die geraden gefahren hast, dann hast du nur die Hälfte von dem abbekommen, dann waren natürlich die Bits alle nicht okay und auf der anderen Seite daneben genau das gleiche, auch nur die Hälfte. Du musstest sozusagen auch diesen halben Track lesen, auf der Hälfte.
Genau, und der eigentliche Klassen, die Sache auch so etwas schwierig zu implementieren und zu hacken machte, ist, dass das Floppy-Disc hatte, 1541, hatte einen eigenen 6502 Prozessor. Das heißt, im Prinzip war die Diskettenstation genauso intelligent wie der Rechner selbst. Da war derselbe Prozessor drin. Und so mit RAM und allem pipa pro. Und man konnte jetzt über dieses RAM, wir reden so von 170 byte, über dieses IEC-Kabel, kannst du aber auch direkt in den RAM rein adressieren. Du kannst also sozusagen Programme in der Floppy-Disc schreiben und dann dort auch exekutieren. Und das war sozusagen the way to go.
Das heißt, man hat da Für die Kopierschutz-Typis.
Genau. Aber eben auch dann für die Hacker-Fraktion.
Die ganzen Copy-Tools, die haben das auch so gemacht, ja.
Genau. Ich hab dann auch mal so ein Disketten-Monitor geschrieben, wo man sozusagen den RAM, der Floppy, auslesen konnte auf dem C64. Das heißt, kannst du so mit dem Cursor runter scrollen und kannst sozusagen durch das Memory-Disc, der Floppy-Disc durchscrollen, um einfach das so zu debunken. Also hat es einfach so den ganzen Hex-Grot, um einfach mal zu schauen, was liegt denn da so rum. Und, naja, dann kam halt so hier, wurde das total die Mode, also wenn Halftracks das kam, ich weiß nicht mehr wann das alles war, wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall der Clou war, dass man eben die Programme da patchen musste, wo sie irgendwie Software geschrieben haben oder was auch immer, um die jetzt wirklich zu knacken.
Also ich hab das irgendwann mal gehört, dass in diesem Folkloro Podcast, der Folklor Podcast, dass Apple damals für ein Mac'n eigenes Deskettenlaufwerk entwickeln wollte und dass die dann auch, ich glaube, wahrscheinlich ein Apple II hatte der nicht auch einen 650.02 Prozessor. Und dass die ein Apple II genommen haben und auch ein Deskettenlaufwerk diesen Prozessor einsetzen wollte und hielt das für relativ einen Overkill und dachte, das wäre damals weit, weit over the top, aber beim C64, im ganz regulären, der verkauft wurde, der hat einen eigenen Prozessor drunter gehabt.
Damals schon. Irgendeine Logik musste das Ding ja auch haben.
Ja klar, ich dachte damals wäre die Scheiße noch richtig teuer gewesen.
Das Ding kostete über 1000 Mark.
Das Laufwerk war teurer als der Rechner, oder?
Teurer oder das gleiche.
Und so in dem Dreh. Deswegen hatte ich auch keins, weil es war scheiße teuer.
Konnte sich halt kaum einer erlauben.
Ich hatte da die Offsetzer.
Press Play to...
Die Datasette war halt das, was man vorher hatte.
Genau, das kenne ich auch. Da hatte man quasi im Endeffekt ein Kassettenlaufwerk dran.
Genau, einfach so das normale.
Das ging ja auch mit Radiokassetten-Recordern, ganz klassischen, oder? Wenn die einen speziellen Eingang hatten.
Nein, dann gesteckertest.
Du konntest da eigentlich auch ein normales Tape verwenden. Du musstest halt nur das da reinflöten lassen.
Das gibt es übrigens auch, das Format für T64. Genau, um Kassetten zu präservieren, oder wie auch immer man es nennt.
Ja, willkommen beim T64 Podcast.
Ganz schön abgefahrener Scheiße muss ich sagen.
Was ist denn so passiert in den letzten zwei Wochen, in der T64?
Ich finde auch, es gibt zu wenig News.
Manchmal hat man das Gefühl, die Plattform könnte fast zu groß sein.
Ich hab ja Gerüchte gelesen, dass da ein neues Gerät raus war. Mit 3 User-Ports. Und ein neues Diskettenlaufwerk. Mit 2 650 02 Prozessoren. Dual Core. Der kann dann auch Quarter-Tracks lesen. Tja, ja, so sieht's aus. Die Geschichte wiederholt sich. Aber es gab durchaus noch interessante Nachrichten. Ich höre gerade, dass wir jetzt wieder auferstanden sind. Was wollen wir denn als nächstes behandeln?
Lass uns doch mal ganz kurz auf dieses. Ich hab ja letzte Woche gefragt nach G1, ob Fragen kamen vor zwei Wochen.
Ja, kamen Fragen.
Es kamen ein paar Fragen, waren nicht so nur nicht viele, können wir aber paaren, glaube ich. Das eine war, zum einen kamen dann noch ein paar Hinweise. Zum Beispiel, dass man im Browser, dass man einfach eine URL anfangen kann zu tippen. Und dann geht dieses Fenster auf, wo das URL im Fenster, da hatte ich mich ziemlich darüber aufgeregt, dass es so kompliziert ist, eine URL da einzugeben, geht auch einfacher, einfach anfangen zu tippen. So, kurzes Fazit nach zwei Wochen, es ist ein tolles Chatgerät, oder es wäre ein grandioses Chatgerät, wenn man...
Da muss ich ja mal den Darts-Wähler noch mal so ein bisschen konzentrieren. Einfach weiter.
Dass es ein sehr, sehr schickes Chatgerät wäre, wenn es auch mal kurz vibrieren würde, wenn eine neue Nachricht ankommt. Weil das ist so, es piept kurz, leise und sehr, sehr unauffällig und dann blinkt eine LED. Aber das kriegt man natürlich alles nicht mit, wenn man es nicht in der Tasche stecken hat. Also chatten kann man damit wirklich jederzeit und überall und fast in zu vielen Situationen.
Also Leute, die das wollen, dass das Telefon vibriert, wenn sie irgendwie chatten und dann eine Nachricht kommt, also ich meine...
Was denn daran auszusetzen?
Das ist ganz schön over gedingt. Also dann sollen sie es halt...
Na ist Linux da? Kann man dann alle Features einschalten?
Ja, das einschalten.
Das wird bestimmt noch gehen. Also jede Wette wird das noch gehen. Also ich finde es... Ansonsten, es knallt halt nach wie vor wie ein Schiff auf hoher See, eine Barke.
Okay, aber eigentlich ist ja mehr die Software interessant und nicht so die Hardware, weil die Hardware kann ja auch jeder mögliche andere Hersteller kommen, oder?
Natürlich, da gibt es ja sogar so ein paar.
Gibt es eigentlich OpenMoco noch? Mir wurde gelacht, ich hab das genau gehört.
OpenMoco, das Projekt gibt es noch. Aber ich hab da jeglichen Glauben verloren, dass das noch irgendwann den zweiten Einfluss hat.
Man kann auf OpenMoco Hardware Android laufen lassen.
Das kann ich mir auch vorstellen, dass das nicht das ist. Wisst du eigentlich, dass dieses Jahr das Jahr des Linux on Desktop ist, oder wie das auch immer heißt?
Ach schon wieder?
Zum 15.
Ach jetzt hat sich diesmal...
Lass mal noch mal kurz beim G1 bleiben. Ich hatte heute ein interessantes Gespräch, wo ich dann das Detail erfahren habe, was wahrscheinlich jeder weiß, aber was ich nicht wusste, ist, die Leute, die Android losgetreten haben, bei Google, das sind die Leute, die vorher Sidekick gemacht haben.
Das wusste ich nicht, wie die Sidekick vorher gemacht haben, aber es gibt doch noch einen Sidekick.
Nee, nicht... Genau. Ja klar, aber die sind da irgendwie abgehauen. Ach, kurz vorher, oder als Microsoft die gekauft hat, keine Ahnung.
Also Danger, dieser Danger Sidekick ist eigentlich ein relativ hübsches Gerät. Für die damalige Zeit auf jeden Fall. So eine abgeschlossene Plattform, mit der man so dreieinhalb Aufgaben relativ gut machen konnte. Also da chatten, Mails glaube ich, ein bisschen rumsurfen mit einem relativ okayen Browser. Und er hatte besonders schick so ein... konnte man so kurz mit dem Finger dran ditchen und dann drehte sich das Display so hoch. Ich glaube, darum hieß das auch Sidekick und dann sah man die Tastatur. Das war eigentlich für die Damals halt echt okay, oder?
Keine Ahnung, ich hab das nie in der Hand gehabt. Auf jeden Fall sind die da irgendwie geflohen oder gegangen oder gegangen worden oder abgeworben worden, keine Ahnung. Auf jeden Fall sind die irgendwie bei Google aufgeschlagen und das waren wohl irgendwie auch Dänen, die in Australien wohnen und so weiter. Auf jeden Fall ist so das Android-Team jetzt irgendwie in Australien. Naja und dann haben die das halt so entwickelt. Aber so richtige Begeisterung macht sich wohl bei Google auch noch nicht bereit. Wie auch immer. War es das zum G1?
Was es noch war, im Wesentlichen war noch die Frage, also ob es denn sowas wie einen iTunes-Store gäbe und die Frage ist, die Antwort darauf ist ein Jein.
Es gibt diesen Android-Marketplace.
Es gibt diesen Android-Marketplace. Die verkaufen jetzt auch Software? Die verkaufen auch Software. Nee, ich meinte Musik. Ob man Musik quasi auch kaufen kann. Direkt auf den Gerät OVZR. Das geht nur in Amerika im Augenblick. Die haben so eine Kooperation mit Amazon mit diesem Amazon MP3. Da unten direkt auch MP3-Sachen runterladen kann. Ob das auch über 3G geht oder nur über WLAN, weiß ich ehrlich gesagt nicht. Aber in Deutschland gibt es zurzeit noch gar nichts. Da muss man das Gerät anschließen an den Rechner. wird das so als Festplatte gemountet, so wie man es von diversen Geräten kennt und dann kann man da Musik drauf spielen, was okay geht. Nichts dramatisches, nichts besonders tolles. Keinerlei Podcast-Unterstützung übrigens. Also es gibt nicht irgendwie so etwas, dass automatisch Podcasts untergeladen werden oder so.
Wie lame.
Wär nun eigentlich theoretisch.
Das ist mega lame, dass die anderen das mit diesem Podcast nicht schneiden. Ich meine, da kann man sich ja nun wirklich auch nicht auch nur ein Stück über Apple beschweren und immer die ganze Zeit diese Alternativen beschwören. Wenn die noch nicht mal in der Lage sind, einen Podcast runterzuladen.
Braucht auch keiner.
Braucht keiner. Na sagt das mal unseren Hörern.
Ups, sind wir schon live?
Wir sind nicht nur live, wir sind auch aufgezeichnet, mein Freund. Gut, G1, Klappe zu.
G1 würde ich sagen, Klappe zu, kann ich dann Montag zurück schicken.
Wo wir gerade so bei Nachrichten-Lage sind, Dennis, gab es nicht Neuigkeiten zu Schnee, Leo und ZFS?
Der hat es gesagt, tut mir leid.
Shit.
Max ist jetzt auch ZFS-Experte, der war bei dem Vortrag.
Stimmt, haben wir schon davon berichtet. Ist ja schon ewig her, es ist schon bald März.
Aber Max hat sich nichts gemerkt.
Max hat vorhin gesagt, haben die Hörer auch schon zugehört, die haben sie glaube ich schon, er hat gesagt, dass die Scheiße funktioniert. Und so gesehen hat er ja auch recht. Aber wenn wir was hätten, müssten wir gar nicht drüber reden, weil dann wäre es einfach mal fucked und gegeben. Und dass wir überhaupt drüber reden müssen, ist schon schade. Aber es gibt diese Macackers Org-Seite, habe ich mal gefunden, und da gibt es ZFS-Neuigkeiten, da hat wohl eine Schnee-Oleopath installiert und hat mal die Versionsnummern verglichen. Ich muss den Artikel mal kurz öffnen hier. Jedenfalls, weil das ZFS gab es als Extension für Leopard, für das aktuelle Betriebssystem. Und das haben sie aber irgendwie eingestellt, weil die mussten Änderungen am Kernel vornehmen. Das machen sie für Leopard natürlich nicht mehr und deswegen gibt es keine ZFS-Updates mehr für Leopard. Aber in dem Snowleo ist es halt drin. Und der hat da herausgefummelt, dass jetzt in der aktuellen ist die Version 145 drin. Und in der, die man für Leopard runterladen kann, ist es halt die 119. Ihr könnt euch auch mal klicken bei mckackers.org.
145, wie aktuell ist die denn?
Das ist eine eigene Apple-Nummer. Das kann man nicht mit der von Sun vergleichen. Die bei Sun haben die 107 inzwischen, aber es sind komplett unterschiedliche Versionsnummern. Das hat nichts zu sagen. Das ist eine Bildnummer von Apple, so wie für den Kernel oder das OS auch.
Das habe ich auch immer anders verstanden.
Das dürft ihr nicht verwechseln. Die 119 ist und 145 jetzt ist eine Apple-eigene Geschichte. Das ZF selbst hat ja auch nochmal eine Versionsnummer. Die sind intern bei 3. Dann gibt es aber auch noch eine andere, die sind gerade bei 13. Es gibt da so viele Versionen, da blickst du gar nicht mehr durch.
Dann gibt es noch diese Versionsnummer des On-Disc-Formats.
Das ist gerade die 13. Da wo sie auch bei FreeBSD bei 13 sind.
Ok, also Wasser ist jetzt angeblich in Schneeleo drin. Man kann jetzt Pools machen.
Das konnte man vorher auch alles schon machen, aber jetzt ist hier halt ein Screenshot dabei, dass es im Disc-Utility auch noch halt angezeigt wird.
Dass explizit Support da ist.
Genau, man kann mit dem Disc-Utility keine Pools anlegen oder so, sonst wird einfach nur angezeigt. Aber es ist ja immer schon mal mehr als vorher.
Ok, also das Disc-Utility weiß jetzt, es gibt ZFS, es gibt Quizz und...
Genau, kann da so ein bisschen hier Health-Status auslesen und dass es irgendwie Striped ist und Number of Devices und wie es heißt und all sowas. Also ja, kann schon mal ein bisschen mehr als vorher, was schon mal ein gutes Zeichen ist, weil irgendwann langsam muss es ja mal, also ZFS in einen GUI rein, weil die sagen ja, dass es für einen Admin ganz easy sein soll. Was nützt einem das ganz easy, wenn es wieder mal nur im Command-Line geht? Also es muss halt ein GUI-Tool her. Und das Disgutility wird es halt sein. Und langsam ist halt was davon.
Okay, und diese ganzen Fehler mit irgendwie Crashes beim Unmounten und Trashlöschen und so weiter?
Das ist alles irgendwie nicht mehr da. Also das Spotlight fährt auch da sauber drüber. Und man kann den Mülleimer jetzt löschen. Und dann sind die Sachen auch wirklich weg. Und all sowas.
Da bin ich ja mal gespannt.
Das war vor echt nicht so. Hast du Sachen in den Mülleimer gemacht? Hast du gelöscht? Also auf dem ZFS in den Mülleimer? Hast du gelöscht? Der hat den Mülleimer nicht gelöscht.
Wie was dann passiert?
Na die sind einfach drin geblieben. Also hat er einfach nicht gemacht. Mussten immer von Hand gelöscht werden.
Also per M.
Ja, in der Command-Landung.
Genau.
Hier gibt es auch nochmal den Hinweis mit, wer hat denn das geschrieben? Ach, das war doch hier Rattet, der DILGER. Meinte so, ja ZFS kommt, aber das wäre ja nichts für normale Benutzer.
Nee, das glaube ich war auf Apple Insider.
Ja, das ist aber von dem DILGER.
Das ist ja das, was hier Max auch schon gesagt hat, dass eigentlich ihn gar nicht interessiert, so einfach funktionieren.
Das tun sie Sachen ja derzeit eigentlich nicht.
Ich habe ehrlich gesagt, ich habe mit HFS Plus gerade schon seit ziemlich vielen Jahren keinen Ärger gehabt, muss ich sagen. Aber ich habe trotzdem halt, also mit meinem...
Ja, weil du es nicht weißt.
Ich habe diese 500 Gigabyte Platten, das stimmt allerdings. Aber eigentlich läuft es ja alles ganz prima und hat bisher noch nicht rumgezickt. Aber wo ich halt so richtig Angst habe, ist immer, wenn ich hier so ein Tri-Fu USB-Schnuffi benutze, dann habe ich echt so ein bisschen Angst um meine Daten.
Ich habe immer Angst um meine Daten.
Also es ist nicht so schlimm, weil es ist eh nur irgendwie ganzen American-Serien-Shit, den ich da irgendwie so hin und her schiebe.
Und 20.000 CD's.
Und da schicken eh sowieso wieder. Und da brauche ich ja nur zwei, das eine habe ich schon. Aber so bei anderen Sachen, so wenn du Backups machst, irgendwie per USB, also da hätte ich schon gerne ein ZFS, dass es dann wieder alles sauber angekommen ist, dass ich das checken kann und dass ich irgendwie ein Jahr später noch weiß, dass alles schickt.
Ja und einfach so dieses kein Fallsystem checkt mehr und dieses Snapshots und das einfach checkt so einfach auf Daten, dass man einfach weiß, also sicher, sicher weiß, dass die Daten da sind.
Also bei einem FreeBSD zu Hause ist das voll cool, wenn der abkackt, weil ich hatte dann noch so ein IPv6-Routerproblem, haben sie mir gefixt, alles voll toll. Aber das ist immer öfter mal abgestürzt in der Zeit. Dann habe ich einfach gebootet und der war sofort wieder oben und der Mirror musste nicht so rebuildet werden, so wie vorher nicht. Stundenlang rebuildt und parallel dazu Fcheck. Du kannst dir ja vorstellen Mirror rebuild und Fcheck in parallel. Das hätte Monate gedauert. Und jetzt ist einfach, wutet, zack, fertig und läuft. Das ist einfach...
Und man weiß, dass die Daten stimmen.
Ja, das machen wir. Ich habe jetzt so ein richtig entspanntes Gefühl. Und das ist das, warum ich Z-Dafest so toll finde. Ich kann einfach besser schlafen.
Besser schlafen als ZFS.
Ja, wollen wir mal hoffen, dass es kommt. Und ansonsten können wir schon wieder vorspulen, weil so viel Neues gibt es eigentlich auch nicht.
Gut.
Aber es gibt noch mehr...
Achso, noch eine ganz kleine Anmerkung. Das ist nicht für PowerPC, da steht doch noch. Also anscheinend, weil Snow Lappert ist alles für PowerPC, Kernel. Also das ganze Snow Lappert ist PowerPC gebaut. Noch. Aber die ZFS-Erweiterung nicht. Die ist nur x86 und x86 64-bit.
Ich fange jetzt mit ein paar Sachen an, die nicht mehr auf dem PowerPC laufen, oder? Bei iPhoto sind so ein paar Features, glaube ich.
Bei iPhoto weiß ich jetzt nicht, aber bei Gerät spenden diese Lessons.
Die Lessons laufen nur noch auf Intel. Also irgendwelche Überblendeffekte und sowas, die nur noch, vielleicht auch wegen Geschwindigkeit, nur noch auf Intel laufen.
Das kann gut sein, dass das wieder Ihr Performance-Cut ist.
So ein bisschen wird es langsam kommen.
So ist das. Es ist vorbei mit PowerPC.
Schmeißt eure PowerPCs weg.
Kauft Intel Mac Minis.
Genau, wie alle anderen. Immerhin, ich meine, sieht wieder ganz gut aus, dass dieses Quartal ganz gut hinhaut. Es gibt jetzt noch keine offiziellen Zahlen, aber die Analysten sind schon wieder am Schätzen.
Wie alles geht den Bach runter, Opel macht Pleite, Saab auch gleich.
Aber Apple schafft zumindest ein solides Quartal.
Rollen, rollen, rollen.
So sieht es aus. Mal gucken, ob es auch stimmt. Das werden wir bald wissen.
Das 17 Zoll MacBook Pro wird jetzt ausgedacht. Ich hab mir genau ein Bild vom Öffnenvorgang angeguckt. Das war nämlich das Bild, wie es aussieht, bevor es geöffnet ist. Und das ist ja doch sehr schick. Es hat ja schon eine Schönheit, wenn man so sieht, so ein MacBook Pro von unten, was einfach so eine glatte Fläche ist.
Oder?
Ohne irgendwelche Blenden und Öffnungen.
Ja, ja. Ich finde das eigentlich auch gar nicht so schlecht.
Lass uns mal alle 17 Zoll MacBook Pros uns schenken.
Wie viel Schraub muss man denn da lösen, um die Festival zu tauschen?
Also bei meinem, den hab ich ja letztes Mal schon erzählt, waren es 23. Und das ist ja auch der Thema der Sendung heute. Übrigens, bei dem Championship-Bloodrunner, im Level 23, ist der einzige Level, wo man keine Gegner hat. Da muss man das Gold nur so einsammeln. Ist aber trotzdem voll schwer.
Ich wollte jetzt noch irgendwas über Lüfter beim Macbook erzählen.
Ja, stimmt, hab ich gelesen. Wo war das? Im FSC-Klog, den ich ja sonst ein bisschen langweilig finde. Also manchmal ist es ganz interessant, aber manchmal ist es langweilig.
Was erwartest du?
Und nicht iPhone, App, jetzt auch, Asteroid.
Leo Schwart teilt nur Sachen, wo er sich auch sicher ist, dass das irgendwie Gehalt hat. Ist egal.
Ist egal.
Was stand da? Maglev-Lüfter oder so?
Maglev-Lüfter. Und zwar habe ich mal da ein bisschen nachgelesen. Und zwar sind das Lüfter, die nicht mehr Kugel gelagert oder halt Rollen gelagert oder was, Gleitlager gibt, sondern die sind halt...
Magnetical Levitation.
Genau. Die sind sozusagen eigentlich gar nicht gelagert, sondern die schweben dann halt, wenn sie sich losbewegen. Und ich habe auch schon überlegt, hä, schweben die? Bauen die so was nur irgendwie beim Laptop ein? Weil was ist denn, wenn ich mein Laptop mal auf dem Kopf betreibe, dann wackelt denn der Lüfter durch die Gegend, weil er nicht mehr so schwebt wie er soll. Aber er schwebt wohl in allen Positionen, magnetisch.
Das ist so wie diese brushless Motoren, das ist halt einfach durch Änderungen der Polung wird sozusagen der Magnetismus im Kreis geschickt und der Lüfter folgt dem.
Ja und er schwebt aber dabei. Und so wie eine Schwebebahn. Nur, dass er sich dabei dreht. Und das ist dann so Transrapid irgendwie im Kreis.
Aber das ist halt keine mechanische Reibung mehr.
Also es ist leiser, es wird nicht so warm und es ist warm.
Na, was heißt nicht so warm? Es ist halt, da sich nichts berührt, ist es egal, wenn es heißer wird. So würde ich das mal behaupten. Weil sie schreiben irgendwas von, ist nicht so wärmeempfindlich und so weiter. Ich sage aber eigentlich, ob der jetzt schneller dreht, dreht der schneller dadurch?
Das weiß ich nicht. Auf jeden Fall leiser, weil er natürlich keine Reibung hat.
Aber die Luftreibung ist ja nach wie vor da. Und das ist ja das Hauptproblem.
Natürlich, der wird nicht komplett unhörbar sein, aber zumindest trägt er nicht mit einem eigener Geräusch, mit mechanischem eigener Geräusch dazu, sondern hat davon nur Luft rausgekauft.
Also ich würde es schon gerne mal mir anhören. Ist das ein Abfallprodukt der Raumpartechnologie? Irgendwer könnte uns ja mal irgendwie einen ausgebauten 17 Zoll Lüfter schicken.
Ich hätte nach wie vor auch gerne so ein MacBook mit dieser Akkutechnik.
Also, Dennis nimmt den Lüfter, ich nehm das 17 Zoll MacBook dazu.
Ich wollte 17 Zoll haben.
Das sieht nämlich ganz schön cool aus, so ein Loadrunner in Fullscreen auf dem 17 Zoll.
Aber ich denke, Loadrunner ist jetzt bald vorbei.
Aber weißt du, was es noch für ein Feature gibt bei dem weißen C64 Emulator? Den PAL Emulation Mode, da schaltest du PAL ein, dann sind alle Farben so scheiße wie damals. Das ist voll toll.
Gibt es einen TSC-Emulation Mode? Der müsste ja noch schlimmer sein.
Einen TSC gibt es auch, dann ist der C64 sogar ein Stück schneller, dann hat er nämlich 1,02 MHz anstatt 0,98. Weil irgendwie wegen der Taktung vom Stromnetz geklaut, oder was auch immer, die dafür Tricks machen. Quatsch, die Taktung ist anders, weil sie ihr Videosignal daran anpassen irgendwie so.
Weil ein TSC mehr Bilder pro Sekunde hat. Das ist aber gar nicht so...
Never the same color.
Never twice the same color?
Ich glaube, ich will keinen 17 Zoll Macbook Pro haben, aber ich sehe durchaus, dass es Leute gibt, die das haben.
Aber der Akku hat irgendwie 1000 Akku haben. 200 milli... 12.000 milliampere Stunden, was irgendwie...
Viermal so viel, als wir meinen?
Doppelt so viel, wie ein Macbook Pro in der Aktuellis.
Warten wir mal ab, wie lange die Dinger wirklich halten.
Wir haben jetzt vier, acht hier oder sowas.
Sie werden lange halten, also länger halten, als sie bisher. Aber wie lange sie wirklich halten, ihr wisst, das ist immer so eine Sache.
Power, hier, 4600.
Ja, aber du hast auch kein aktuelles Macbook Pro.
Mehr oder was?
Ich weiß es nicht, aber ich habe irgendwo gesehen...
Nee, aber der 17 Zoller, der braucht natürlich auch ein bisschen mehr. Also nur weil er den dreifachen Akku hat, heißt ja nicht, dass er dreimal so lange hält.
Nein, das heißt natürlich nicht, aber das heißt, dass die... dass die ungefähr, dass die da deutlich mehr reinkriegen. Also zum Beispiel meiner hat schon mal deutlich mehr als deiner. Bei mir sind es 5220 mAh. Na siehste. Das kommt davon, wenn man einen neuen Akku hat.
Und du hast sogar hier so ein LED-Bildschirm und sparst voll Strom und Dicke nicht.
Charge Remaining.
Und Full ist aber, nee, Full ist 4841. Ist ja ein Ding.
Haben wir das Thema durch, wa? Oder gibt es noch irgendwas zu sagen zum 17 Zoller? Ich glaube nicht.
17 Zoll ist toll.
Ich würde noch mal kurz gerne auf Schneeleo zurückkommen. Da gab es irgendwo, jetzt habe ich aber die Quelle nicht mehr am Start, das Gerücht, dass es auch Call Location in Schneeleo schafft.
Das habe ich auch gelesen. Das ist der Call Location Service aus dem iPhone.
Die machen das natürlich dann auch hier über den Skyhawk Wireless, über die WLAN-Stationen erstmal, weil GSM haben sie ja nicht.
Oder vielleicht haben sie ja auch bald GSM, das fände ich ja mal cool.
Oder GPS.
Oder GPS, genau. Haben wir ja drüber gerätselt, wir waren ja dafür, andere nicht so, aber ich bin ja auch immer noch dafür.
Du bist nicht dafür.
Also ich glaub, ich wüsste nicht wofür.
Das ist so billig, einfach renn damit, genauso wie sie die Kamera einbauen und die keiner braucht.
Na zum Lokalisieren deines Ortes.
Guck mal, oder die Fernbedienung haben sie mit reingelegt, braucht kein N.
Doch.
Außerdem liegt die jetzt nicht mehr wieder dabei.
Stimmt, haben sie abgeschafft.
Aber es gibt nach wie vor den Empfänger, aber ich meine GPS, also erstmal stört es nicht und zweitens ist das einfach geil, wenn du halt irgendwo bist. Ich meine, kennst du nicht, dass eine Situation eine tolle Sache ist? Ja, du klappst einfach mit deinem fucking Laptop auf und dein Google Maps zeigt einfach sofort an, wo du bist und du musst halt nicht auf deinem iPhone irgendwie...
Mein Google Maps zeigt mir sofort an, wo ich bin, wenn ich mich nicht zufälligerweise in einem Gebäude aufhalte, wo ich kein GPS empfangen habe.
Da hast du dann Skyhook Wireless.
Da hab ich Skyhook Wireless, das reicht. Das ist meine Meinung.
Ja, und wenn du draußen auf dem Acker bist, oder wenn du irgendwo bist, wo das eben einfach all das nicht gibt...
Dann hab ich keinen 17 Zoll MacBook Pro, weswegen mein Akku eh nicht so lange durchhält, weswegen ich eh tot bin. Aus dem Teich da auch kein WLAN.
Und man kann eine 17 Zolle Non-Glossy kaufen, wird mir ja noch über unten's channels berichtet. Ich find Glossy ja immer noch voll toll.
Ja, aber es gibt da halt so Fraktionen, die das nicht finden.
Ja, aber Call Location finde ich prinzipiell ein großartiges Feature. Also ich hab nichts dagegen, dass man sich lokalisieren lassen kann.
Es hat da einfach zu sein. Ich meine, das ist einfach, das muss da rein.
Oder Call Location?
Call Location. Da muss auch GPS rein. Da muss auch GSM rein und da muss auch UMTS rein. Und ich sag dir auch nochmal warum. Das ist mir nämlich vor kurzem nochmal so richtig bewusst geworden, als ich in der Bahn gefahren bin. Diese ganzen Dongles, das ist ja alles schön und gut, aber die haben natürlich ein grundsätzliches Problem, das sie auch nicht überkommen können, einfach von der Art und Weise, wie sie angeschlossen sind. Das handelt sich dabei um autarke Systeme. Du steckst da die SIM-Karte rein, die haben ihre eigene Firmware und diese Firmware ist dafür zuständig, sich einzubuchen oder nicht. Mit anderen Worten, was der Computer nicht tun kann, Strom sparen? Nein, der kann nicht monitoren, ob ein Netz da ist. Sondern du musst ja immer einen W-Vorgang anstarten und dann mit irgendwie PPP oder AT oder was auch immer, halt wählen. Nach dem Motto, jetzt probiere ich nochmal, ob da jetzt vielleicht gerade in diesem Moment was ist.
Also du hast nicht so etwas, das quasi in dem Moment, in dem eins da ist, alle Programme mitgeteilt.
Das iPhone monitort die ganze Zeit, ob da irgendwo was ist und joint diesem Netz halt automatisch. Und habe ich so einen Dongle an meinem Rechner, dann geschieht das natürlich nicht. Weil das OS diese Information nicht hat. Das OS kann überhaupt nicht darüber automatisieren. Das kann einfach dieses Netz nicht mehr. Das ist wie mit Ethernet. Wenn ich da ein Kabel reinstecke, dann merkt der Link und dann geht das Interface einfach hoch. Und das ist halt mit so einem Dongle nicht machbar. Da gibt es den Link nicht. Sondern den Link gibt es immer erst, wenn man selber aktiv wird und nochmal probieren und nochmal probieren.
Bei dem Dongle können natürlich die theoretischen Informationen irgendwie ans Betriebssystem übergeben. Habe ich Netz, habe ich kein Netz, aber das ist halt nicht so weit generalisiert.
Genau, so funktionieren die nicht. Ich meine, die müssten sich dann anders präsentieren, die müssten sich eigentlich wie eine Ethernet-Shit-Stelle da präsentieren. Aber das ist natürlich jetzt auch nicht so das, was man eigentlich will. Zumal auch so Informationen wie Empfangsstärke und so weiter nicht wirklich durchkommen. Ja, du hast dann in diesem blöden Huawei-Dongle, da gibt es dann halt irgendwie für das eine oder andere Gerät auch eine downloadbare Firmware, die ist so eher so irgendwo so zwischen eh und eh. Funktioniert so ein bisschen gerade so eben, aber dann kriegst du es eben auch nicht für jedes Donglechen und so und das ist alles ganz furchtbar und grausam. Das hat einfach zu enden, also ich finde einfach Apple hat zu erkennen, dass Netzwerk unterwegs wird halt einfach darüber hergestellt.
Also schick wäre es natürlich schon, wenn das mal langsam kommen würde, das stimmt.
So ist das. Aber ich habe ja auch immer so Ansichten, die nicht jedermann teilt.
Genau. Zum Beispiel, was hast du irgendwas mit xhtml in Mails?
Ja, ich habe gesagt, dass ich es für eine verdammt gute Idee halte, wenn E-Mails sich aus HTML bzw. xhtml zusammensetzen würden. Da ging natürlich dann, das habe ich auf Twitter gemacht, da könntest du dir in etwa vorstellen, was dann passiert ist. Dann sind da so alle irgendwie aufgesprungen und haben Jehova, Jehova, Jehova gesagt, weil ich habe ja das böse H-Wort gesagt. Ich habe ja HTML-E-Mail gesagt. Der Punkt ist nur, ich habe das zwar gesagt, aber angekommen ist eine andere Information, weil sie mich nämlich nicht verstanden haben. Was ich nämlich gesagt habe ist, ich schätze, wenn ich möchte gerne die Möglichkeit haben, meine Mail aus xhtml zusammensetzen. Was sie verstanden haben ist, dass du bunte Newsletter verschicken willst. Vielleicht will ich auch bunte Newsletter verschicken. Das würde ich jetzt an der Stelle auch nicht als falsch empfinden. Nur mir ging es darum primär ums xhtml. Und nicht um das, was da mal so in html mit drin war, mit irgendwie fontgleich und diesen ganzen schnickes Kram.
Na ja, aber ich würde sagen, das kannst du schon, oder?
Fontgleich. In xhtml, nein.
Fontgleich gibt es nicht in xhtml, du kannst doch einfach xhtml-Code als Mail verschicken und dann kommt auf der anderen Seite eine Mail in xhtml an.
Ja, und das soll sie ja auch. Aber alle nehmen heutzutage, das war als eine Bedrohung, weil sie natürlich dann an Spam denken. Bloß ist es natürlich, Spam kommt so oder so, ob der nun in html ist oder nicht. Also der nervt als Text genauso, wie er in html war.
Der nervt nicht alle, so ein cooles iPhone, das irgendwie das Mail-Programm auch irgendwie Webkit-Unterstützung hat.
Naja, aber jeder moderne Browser, jeder E-Mail, jeder E-Mail, der ist total verwöhnt.
Es gibt noch Leute, die lesen ihre Mails mit Matt.
Moment, ich sag ja nicht, dass die Mail nicht auch noch eine Text-Alternative enthalten soll. Der Punkt ist nur, du kannst einfach in html bestimmte Dinge machen, die in einer normalen Text-Mail einfach nicht gehen.
Und zwar?
Du kannst zum Beispiel keinen Link als solchen kennzeichnen, sondern du bist darauf angewiesen, dass der Empfänger irgendeine geartete Detection hat. Dann hast du solche Probleme wie mit Zeilenumbrüchen in langen URLs. Und du willst halt auch nicht, wenn du so eine 5-Zeilen-URL mit irgendwie, tralala, du weißt was ich meine, diese unglaublich langen Mails, die auch teilweise URLs hier halt auch sinnvoll sein können, weil sie keine Ahnung was für Informationen an den Webserver geben, welche Ressource denn nun gefragt ist. Und in html kann ich halt einfach sagen, hier ist ein Link und ich kann ihn vor allem auch benennen. Und dann taucht dieser Link halt auch in der E-Mail als benannt auf. Listen. Ich möchte gerne Listen machen. Wenn ich in der Liste in normal Text mache, habe ich wieder dieses Text-Umbruch-Problem. Ist der Listen-Eintrag zu lang?
Aber das Problem ist doch seit Jahren gelöst.
Nein, das ist nicht gelöst.
Doch, da verschickt mir einfach eine Word-Appei.
Na toll. Also ich meine, das kann mir dann aber keiner erzählen, dass ich hier kein xhtml verwenden soll und stattdessen Word.
Weißt du, was ich doof finde an HTML?
Moment, du wolltest wissen, was alles nicht geht? Ich rufe es dir ins Bewusstsein. Listen sind sehr wichtig. Also erstmal geht es ja nicht nur darum, Listen zu haben. Ich will auch nummerierte Listen haben, zum Beispiel.
Ich bin ein Freund von Listen.
Ich will, na klar bin ich ein Freund von Listen. Und ich bin auch ein Freund von Tabellen. Ich will auch eine Tabelle unterbringen und schreib mal eine Tabelle in Text. Das geht nicht. Du machst das halt einfach nicht. Und so weiter. Also das sind so diese Kernsachen. Mir geht es einfach darum, dass man einfach Metainformationen als solche auch deklarieren kann. Und da wäre XHTML eine tolle Sache. Ob man dann CSS erlaubt, ob man das dann in seinem Client, dem der Mail sozusagen zugesteht, dass sie auch CSS-Attribute liefert, das steht auf einem ganz anderen Blatt. Das kann man auch ausschalten. Bloß das Gute ist, dass halt XHTML auch ohne CSS immer noch eine wertvolle Information darstellt.
Naja, aber Listen kannst du auch in HTML ohne CSS darstellen und du kannst auch Tabellen ohne CSS darstellen.
Das ist heißt Struktur und Style.
Da braucht man kein XHTML für, da kann man auch normales HTML für nehmen, gutes altes.
Ja, natürlich braucht man kein XHTML, man kann auch HTML nehmen, aber ich bitte dich, das ist mit diesem HTML, das vergessen wir aber erst mal gleich.
Mit HTML vergessen wir mal gleich?
Weil das nicht maschinenlesbar ist. Du siehst halt diesen ganzen Schrott da draußen.
Ich meine, XHTML ist glaube ich, will ich mal sagen...
XHTML und HTML ist von der Semantik her, hat keine Zukunft. Das ist einfach mal das, was alles CMSs der Zukunft bei Default ausspucken werden. Ja, was hast du? Da kenne ich aber ganz viele, die das nicht verstehen.
Mach eine Standard-Wordpress-Installation.
WordPress ist kein CMS, WordPress ist ein Haufen Scheiß.
Nur so als Beispiel, aber welches, welches... Es gibt wie viel Prozent...
Jungs, wir haben ein bisschen mehr Fokus hier.
Die Python-Welt zum Beispiel liebt diesen Gedanken. Und das Ding ist, in dem Moment, wo du ein CMS machst, was sich über seinen Content auch bewusst ist, dann ist er auch in der Lage, das ordentlich zu rendern. Und wenn man das ordentlich rendern kann, und wenn man weiß, was der Inhalt ist, und wenn der Inhalt nicht handgeschriebenes HTML ist, was er nicht zu sein hat, dann kannst du das auch normal maschinenlesbares XHTML übersetzen. Wie auch immer. Tatsache ist, in E-Mails wäre es eine tolle Sache, wenn man sich da mal ein bisschen entspannt, weil es gibt nämlich überhaupt keine einzigen Mail-Client, deren ordentlichen XHTML-Editor bietet.
Dass man direkt den XHTML-Code schreiben kann sozusagen?
Nein, nicht das.
Oder HTML-Code?
Nein, dass man sagen kann, ich will jetzt hier eine Liste anlegen. Ich hätte jetzt hier gerne eine Liste. Das geht auch in deinem blöden Mail ab nicht. Da kannst du irgendwie bold machen und irgendwie Fonts wählen und so den ganzen Scheiß. Das ist das, was man als Rich Text bezeichnet. Und das ist ja auch sozusagen diese Konfusion. Ich habe gesagt, ich finde HTML in E-Mails wäre mal eine ganz tolle Idee. Und dann kamen halt alle auf den Gedanken, ich hätte gesagt, ich wäre der Meinung, dass Rich Text eine tolle Idee wäre. Von Rich Text halte ich nicht viel.
Also mit Rich Text meinst du, dass man bold, kursiv, andere Schriften und sowas verwenden kann?
Genau, dass es im Wesentlichen um die Formatierung geht. Mir geht es nicht um die Formatierung, mir geht es um die Struktur. Ich will einfach sagen, worum es sich handelt. Ich will sagen, hier ist ein Link, ich will sagen, hier ist eine Liste, hier ist eine Tabelle. Und dann soll sie von dem Kleinen so gerendert werden, wie es der User für richtig erachtet. Und dann kann er dann auch in seinen Preferenzes einen kleinen Haken kriegen, mit irgendwie CSS erlauben. Und dann dürfen diese XHTML-Mails auch CSS inline, wohlgemerkt, enthalten. Nicht mit irgendwie Link auf Style Sheet und dann nochmal Web-Zugriff oder so. Auch keine Bilder. Ich habe auch von Bildern nichts gesagt. Okay, klar, IMG kann man dann noch mit einbauen, kann man theoretisch auch inline machen. Das ist alles nicht das Problem. Man muss nicht unbedingt nochmal extern eine URL dafür haben. Und dann wäre das halt auch top.
Okay, ich habe jetzt gedacht die ganze Zeit, als du sagtest, du willst unbedingt XHTML haben, dass du irgendwas gegen HTML hast, weil XHTML würde ich mal wirklich, also das ist jetzt aus einer Web-Entwickler-Michtung...
Für mich ist HTML und XHTML eigentlich dasselbe und HTML ist nur für Leute, die noch nicht verstanden haben, dass man eigentlich besser XHTML verwenden sollte.
Nee, XHTML ist tot.
Wieso ist das tot?
Weil XHTML kommt.
Ja, es kommt auch XHTML5, mein Freund, selbstverständlich.
Das ist, ich glaube, das ist...
HTML5, Junge, es gibt zwei Sachen. Es gibt Syntax und es gibt Semantik. HTML5 ist Semantik. Und es gibt sie in zwei Syntaxen. Und die eine Syntax ist die SGML-Syntax und das andere ist die XML-Syntax. So, und SGML ist 1970 und XML ist 21. Ich weiß. Ich mache 21. Jahrhundert. Meinetwegen kannst du dich mit 1970 intensiv auseinandersetzen. Ich kann dir auch noch ein paar interessante Filme aus der Zeit empfehlen. Ja, da gibt es ein paar ganz gute, die kann man sich dazu noch anschauen, passend zum Code sozusagen. Aber eigentlich, ich hätte dann halt doch lieber...
Was ist an XHTML besser als an HTML?
Es ist maschinenlispal.
Es ist maschinenlispal, genau. Glaubst du, dass es jemals ein Web geben wird, bei dem alle Seiten XHTML-fähig sein werden? Nö.
Aber es gibt einen Mime-Type, den kann man in so einer E-Mail einfach reinschreiben. Dann kann man auf der anderen Seite sagen, wenn da XHTML kommt, dann zeig ich das an. Punkt.
Dein Client muss sowieso auch HTML können.
Mein Mailclient muss das nicht können.
Warum nicht?
Ich will nur, dass der XHTML...
Du wirst ungefähr 90% aller Mails nicht lesen können, weil auch XHTML-Code, auch wenn sie behaupten, es ist XHTML, wird kein XHTML ankommen. Du wirst einfach deine Mails nicht sehen können. Und da die...
Es steht ja jedem frei, auch ein Mailclient zu haben, der auch HTML dekodiert. Das ist nicht das, was ich meine. Was ich meine ist, ich möchte gerne in der Lage sein, XHTML zu OR-fahren. Ich will das schreiben können. Ich will das Gefühl haben, dass ich eine spermerfreie E-Mail verschicken kann.
Spermerfrei?
Ja, die unbefleckte Empfängnis. Verstehst du? Einfach Reinheit. Maria.
Warum willst du ein maschinenlesbares Format schreiben, wo die Maschinenlesbarkeit sowieso hinfällig ist?
Die ist nicht hinfällig.
Fast nicht hinfällig.
Wieso ist die nicht hinfällig?
Weil 95% aller Webseiten...
Ich rede nicht von Webseiten.
Naja, aber ich meine, was zeigt dir deine XHTML-Mail an, wenn du ein Apple-Produkt nimmst? WebKit. WebKit kann eh HTML.
Du, wenn da drin steht, dass der Mime-Type...
Ja? Wenn das der...
HTML plus XML ist, dann zeigt er auch genau das an. Das ist so. Und das benutzt bloß derzeit niemand im Web. Ja, wegen der allgemeinen Kompatibilitätsprobleme. Aber das ist doch mir egal. Ich will das schreiben können. Und wenn ich das schreiben kann und wenn ich das verschicke und mein Mailklein das tut, dann spende ich dem Web oder dem Internet, spende ich halt einfach reine Daten.
Du kannst genauso gut einfach HTML-Code verstecken. Das ist genauso gut.
Ja, klar kannst du das tun. Ich kann auch ein PC kaufen und Windows installieren.
Na ja.
HTML ist das Windows 95 irgendwie und XHTML ist halt einfach mal Mac OS X. Selbstverständlich, ich hab das doch eben schon erklärt. Semantik und Syntax. Semantik ist, was in HTML5 an Features dazu kommt. Syntax ist, wie du schreibst. Und du kannst natürlich HTML5 sowohl in SGML als auch in XML schreiben.
Mir ist das absolut klar, dass das geht, dass man die gleichen Texts auch theoretisch verwenden könnte. Es ist aber die Frage, ob sie überhaupt irgendjemand umsetzt und ob jemand nachher einen Parcel dafür schreibt.
Natürlich.
Selbstverständlich.
So, nächstes Thema, Jungs.
Das ist mal hier ausgereizt, die Leute, die droppen hier schon alle aus dem Channel.
Ist das so?
Ist ja total langweilig.
Ich finde, das muss mal gesagt werden. Ich bin aufgefordert worden, mich dazu zu äußern und mal ganz klar zu formulieren, warum ich der Meinung bin, dass das eine gute Idee ist. Jetzt könnt ihr mich ja gerne in den Kommentaren niederwalzen und der Meinung sein, wir sollten irgendwie auf dem technologischen Standard des vorletzten Jahrhunderts stehen bleiben. Ich bin nicht dafür. Ich lasse mich davon auch nicht einschöcheln, von diesem, es wird nie kommen, irgendwie die Erde ist flach. Ja, das ist doch alles Quatsch.
Plain Text.
Also es ist einfach schlicht und ergreifend so, dass auch die meisten Webseiten, die behaupten, rein eine XRTM-L-Code auszuliefern, es einfach nicht tun.
Ich benutze heute noch OE anstatt Umlaute, weil es geht einfach nirgends.
Gleis?
Ja klar, das kann wirklich jeder.
Inzwischen?
Das war schon sehr lange. Was wäre denn jetzt so ein Themenbereich, mit dem wir sozusagen wieder alle aus dem Schlaf wecken könnten? Noch mal ein bisschen Snow Leopard?
Hat man schon. Oder fällt dir noch was ein?
Ja mir fällt gerade noch was ein. Es gibt auch News zum Thema Snow Leopard Server. Und zwar bauen sie ja da kräftig um. Und was ich interessant fand, ist, dass sie den Mailserver wegschmeißen, den sie bisher verwendet haben.
Welchen haben sie denn verwendet?
Sie haben Cyrus verwendet.
Und jetzt benutzen sie was?
Taubenschlag. Und zwar tun sie das wohl deshalb, weil Cyrus ist ja das Projekt, was imap quasi losgetreten hat. Es gibt da einen interessanten Test, so einen imap-Test, und den haben sie irgendwie mal gegen alles laufen lassen. Und dann ist dann Cyrus, wie auch fast alle anderen, einfach mit vielen Errors sozusagen. Also sie implementieren einfach imap nicht korrekt. Der einzige, der da irgendwie rauskommt, ist Daft Golden. Der ist halt irgendwie kleiner, schlanker, schneller, skaliert besser. Und sie tauschen das jetzt aus. Naja, bei Mac OS X Server kann dir das eh Wurst sein. Du machst einfach so einen Haken, Mail Server an und dann läuft der. Und das haben sie vor. Und was sie halt auch machen, das ist ja auch keine Neuigkeit, das ist mir bloß nochmal so klar geworden, sie tauschen auch wie der Adressbook-Server intern, also wie das Sharing von Adressinformationen im Netz funktioniert aus. Und machen jetzt CardDAF. Also so wie sie schon CalDAF, sprich WebDAF-basiertes Kalendersharing gemacht haben, für ihren Kalenderserver, der ja auch Open Source ist, gibt es jetzt auch einen CardDAS Server, der das halt sozusagen mit V-Cards macht, also mit Addressbook-Informationen. Das heißt, auch da gehen sie auf HTTP-basierte Technologie, weg von LDAP. Und das Ganze wiederum ist dann die Foundation für das, was ich jetzt mal so salopp Apple Exchange nenne. Also das Exchange von Apple. Also ich gehe davon aus, dass Snowleo Server out of the box eine Maschine ist, gegen die du dein iPhone so sinken kannst, wie du das jetzt heute mit Microsoft's Exchange machen kannst.
Dann muss aber erstmal eine neue Firmenversion kommen, ne?
Da kommt natürlich eine neue Version. Aber das passt ja auch ganz gut zusammen. Ich meine, wann kommt das nächste iPhone?
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was ein Schimmer.
Wann kommt die nächste World Wide Developers Konferenz?
Im Juni.
Auch irgendwie so in dem Zeitraum. Wann kommt Snowleo raus? Auch irgendwie so in dem Zeitraum. Also das ist meiner Meinung nach kein ungeschicktes Timing. Und ich wäre nicht überrascht, wenn Sie jetzt Snowleo Server quasi als Datenhub für kleine Companies pushen, auch im Hinblick auf iPhone Syncing. Und da sind wir halt wieder schön bei dem ganzen Syncing-Thema angekommen, wo sich ja sowieso gerade eine Menge tut. Weil bisher hat sich der Apple eigentlich nicht besonders mit Ruhm bekleckert. Das Telefon kann derzeit noch nicht mehr kalt.
Was ist denn das Grottich?
Es gibt nur dieses komische Mogami, was irgendwie zwar so ein bisschen funktioniert, aber wenn du halt auch nur ein Hauch Flexibilität haben willst, dann stehst du so ein bisschen blöd da. Apple ist evil. Und ich rechne halt damit, dass sie das in dem nächsten Release, der iPhone-Software, irgendwie in den Griff kriegen. Also dass es einen 3.0 gibt und dass sie dort eine neue Sync-Option haben und dann heißt das irgendwie Apple Open Schnickes Exchange.
Hoffentlich kommen auch mal die iPhone-Notifications.
Das wird sicherlich auch Teil der ganzen Geschichte sein.
Ich habe übrigens gerade den Grund gefunden, warum sobald sich XHTML nicht mehr über HTML durchsetzen würde.
Wir reden jetzt nicht mehr über HTML.
Und zwar ist ein verdammt guter Grund.
Syncing, genau. Und da ist ja auch einiges passiert. Google, hat das schon mal jemand ausprobiert eigentlich? Google Sync.
Genau, Google Sync ist...
Erklär mal, was ist da passiert?
Google ist auch...
Weil sie jetzt Synken oder was?
Also meine Daten wollen...
Ich will auch deine Daten.
Dann kriegst du aber nicht, in Google auch nicht. Was sie mal anbieten sollen, ist irgendwie...
Ich hab da eine Daten...
Space, wo ich mit Kryptozettas meine Blöcke speichern kann.
Jaja, du wiederholst dich aber auch.
Also Google Sync kannst du auf Amazon machen.
Und die können von mir aus auch Krypto Synken, dann können wir über Sync reden.
Das kannst du auf Amazon machen.
Muss alles gehen eigentlich, das kann ja so schwer werden.
Krypto Sync, wie soll das denn gehen?
Die sollen ja eigentlich nur...
Auf Fallsystem-Basis.
Deine Daten würde ich speichern, aber die müssen den Inhalt ja eigentlich nicht kennen, oder?
Machst du dein ZFS-Image auf Amazon S3.
Aber für ein vernünftiges Syncing muss das Programm doch Bescheid wissen.
Das Programm kann ja Bescheid wissen, aber die müssen nicht Bescheid wissen.
Also müssen die Bescheid wissen, weil die haben ein Programm am Laufen, das sich mit deinem Programm auf deinem Rechner synkt.
Nein, er meint halt ein Filesystem-basiertes Syncing.
Ja, aber darüber kann ich ja nicht Synken. Also ich meine, darüber kann ich ja...
Aber über.mec Synken. Kannst auch über.mec iDisk Synken.
Ja, aber wenn ich jetzt zwei Telefonnummern an zwei Stellen geändert habe, einmal auf meinem Rechner und einmal auf meinem iPhone, wie will er das zusammenführen, ohne zu wissen, dass es sich um eine Telefonnummer handelt? Also ich meine, man könnte die Telefonnummer selber verschlüsseln.
Ja, man tatscht da halt so ein File, wo irgendwie drinsteht, was sich hier...
Und dann hast du auf zwei Seiten Touch.
Das kann man alles lösen.
Das ist alles lösbar, glaube ich.
So wird dann halt beide verschlüsselte Telefonnummern da vor Ort gehalten und wenn mein Rechner, mein zweiter dann wieder synkt, sieht er, aha, da ist jetzt eine neue dazugekommen und dann kann der das entscheiden. Also alles, was die da online machen, kann ja mal...
Okay, das hat Google auf jeden Fall noch nicht. Was sie aber gemacht haben, sie haben von einer anderen Evil-Firma, von Microsoft, haben sie das Exchange-Protokoll lizenziert. Und darum ist jetzt quasi Google in das Geschäft eingestiegen mit der Synchronisation von, dass man seinen Google-Mail-Account und seinen Google-Addressbook und seinen Google-Kalender, ne, den Mail-Account ausgerechnet noch nicht, per Über-Exchange mit seinem Handy synchronisieren kann. Und das funktioniert auf diversen Geräten da draußen, unter anderem auch auf unserem heiß geliebten iPhone. Und darum hab ich das mal ausprobiert, weil das ist ja auch so ein schönes Feature an diesem G1, so dieses OVCR-Kalender zu Synken. Was muss man denn dafür machen? Das ist ganz hübsch. Und darum hab ich das beim iPhone gemacht. Es ist nichts, was man mal eben so ausprobieren kann, weil wenn man das einrichtet, also es geht so, man geht auf die Seite von diese Google-Sync-Seite und liest sich eine Anleitung durch, dann muss man einen neuen Mail-Account anlegen in den Einstellungen. Ein Mail-Account, der übrigens für alles außer Mail zuständig ist.
Was, man muss einen Mail-Account anlegen, über den man dann keine Mail empfangen kann?
Über den kannst du dann keine Mail empfangen. Also den Teil haben sie offensichtlich nicht mittels lizenziert, den Mail-Teil, sondern das musst du weiterhin per IMAP machen. Also wenn du dann ein Gmail-Account hast, bräuchtest du und du willst beide Features nutzen, musst du dir zum einen einen ganz normalen Gmail-IMAP-Account anlegen auf dem iPhone und eben einen Exchange-Account, mit dem du alles synchronisierst, also Kalender und Adressbuch, aber nicht die Einstellungen, nicht Mails. Und da ist eine sehr intuitive oder eine gute Anleitung von Google, wie man das einrichtet. Die beste, die ich bisher gesehen habe, weil dir auch sowas sagt, ja, dann ändert sich plötzlich, also, richtig toll ist das auch nicht gemacht von Apple, wie man da diesen Exchange-Server einrichtet. Man richtet den ein und dann sagt einem das iPhone, oh, wenn du das jetzt machst, kannst du natürlich gerne tun, aber dann werden auch alle deine Adressen in deinem Adressbuch gelöscht auf dem iPhone. Wenn du zum Beispiel deine Adressen syncst, weil die werden dann für den Exchange-Server geholt. Genauso sieht das aus mit den Kalendern.
Aber ich muss das nicht tun. Ich kann für jeden einzelnen Bereich sagen, will ich nicht syncen.
Du kannst entweder nur den Kalender oder nur das Adressbuch syncen. Und das klappt soweit relativ okay. Was beim Adressbuch mich sehr genervt hat, dass die Bilder nicht mit dabei sind.
Du hast das mit dem Kalender syncen ausprobiert?
Ich hab beides ausprobiert. Und mit dem Adressbuch syncen ist das das einzige Problem, was mir da aufgefallen ist. Also erstmal steht man sehr schockiert da. Man macht das und man geht in sein Telefonbuch und es ist komplett leer. Und unter vorherige Anrufe sieht man nur irgendwelche Telefonnummern, die man nicht zuaunen kann. Und dann nach und nach lädt er sich dann per Exchange von seinem Gmail-Account die Daten runter, so sie dann da vorhanden sind. Und dann hat man die auf seinem iPhone drauf. Und eigentlich funktioniert das alles, soweit auch ganz hübsch eben, bis auf die Bilder, die fehlen. Weil ich glaube, dass das Gmail-Adressbuch die kann, aber ich kenn kein Tool, mit dem man das Adressbuch so mit Gmail syncen kann, dass auch die Bilder übertragen werden. Die sind dabei flöten gegangen. Und das ist doch ein Feature, an das ich mich sehr gewöhnt habe, dass ich bei einem Anruf sehe, wer mich da anruft, dass ich gleich ein Bild da habe.
Aber man kann den Account sozusagen dazu nutzen, um zumindest seine Kalender darüber zu syncen.
Man kann auf jeden Fall seine Kalender darüber syncen. Und muss man dann einfach nur einschalten.
Aber das ersetzt dann auch alle.
Das ersetzt alle und man kann maximal fünf Kalender darüber syncen.
Wenn das nicht so beknackt zu konfigurieren wäre in iCal, dann wäre das ja durchaus eine Option, dass man sagt, man speichert sozusagen überhaupt nicht mehr lokal, sondern nur noch auf Google. Aber dann kannst du halt offline deinen Kalender.
Ja, das ist aber, das ist, naja, das ist... Moment mal, Moment mal, nee, nee, nee. Also es ist, es ist, also eine wirklich tolle Lösung gibt es nicht. Ich bin jetzt dazu, ich hab vorher, ich hab sowieso schon immer meinen iCall mit Google gesynkt. Einfach weil ich, weil es so viele Kalender gibt, die ich mit anderen Leuten teilen muss. Dafür hab ich BusySync genommen. Das ist ein kleines, gut funktionierendes Programm, was allerdings ein paar Dollar kostet. Es gibt noch eine andere Variante, die eine kostenlose, die auch von Google sozusagen so ein bisschen unterstützt wird. Ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, wie die heißt. Ich suche das nochmal raus kurz. Und die machen das über CalDAF. Und zwar ist das ein Tool, das leht man im Wesentlichen einmal runter. Und das richtet einem, dann muss man iCall beenden und dann sagt man, welche Kalender man gerne drin haben möchte und dann sieht man die alle in iCall. Und zwar...
Das heißt für iCal ist es ein lokaler Kalender, aber du benutzt das Tool, um sozusagen unabhängig von iCal die zu syncen.
Du nutzt das Tool, um die einmalig einzurichten und iCall sync danach über CalDAV das Ganze. Das Einzige, was das macht, ist ja sozusagen die Einstellung schon mal richtig schön vorbereitet. Was auch notwendig ist, weil man braucht für jeden Kalender, den man darüber hat, muss man einen eigenen CalDAV-Server anlegen. Also das ist dann ein bisschen doof, weil man sieht dann so links in der Liste sieht man dann für jeden...
Wenn ich jetzt die Google-Kalender in iCal eintrage, dann hab ich das ja auch immer. Muss immer einen neuen Account machen für jeden einzelnen Kalender und kann nicht mehrere Kalender pro Account machen.
Achso, dann wird das Haar genauso aussehen.
Ja, das ist völlig beknackt.
Das ist eher doof, sodass ich dann bei BusySync geblieben bin. Aber mit BusySync funktioniert es...
Hab ich schon mehrfach gehört, dass das gut funktioniert.
Ich trag meine Kalender in iCal ein, meine Termine, und die landen dann kurze Zeit später natürlich nicht sofort, aber auf dem iPhone und umgekehrt funktioniert es genauso gut. Das ist wirklich eine schöne Sache. Und...
Ich kann BusySync auch benutzen, um meinen lokalen iCal-Kalender mit einem Google-Kalender zu singen.
Genau. Dafür ist es ja heiß gekauft. Weil ich mit ein paar anderen Leuten einen Google-Kalender pflege und wir ironischerweise das damals auch unbedingt auf dem iPhone haben wollten.
Okay, und für iCal ist das dann aber nach wie vor ein lokaler Kalender.
Für iCal sieht das aus wie ein lokaler Kalender, kriegt davon gar nichts mit, weswegen es gut funktioniert.
Also ich sag dir, dieses Syncing ist eigentlich ein Kandidat ähm es ist eigentlich eine Killer-Up. Also ein System, was gut Synken kann, und zwar Synken von SYNK mir meine Dateien bis SYNK mir meine spezifischen Daten und SYNK mir das zwischen lokalen Geräten, SYNK mir das mit einem Internet-Server und so weiter.
Das ist ein ungelöstes Problem nach wie vor.
Das ist ein vollkommen ungelöstes Problem und ich finde auch alle Ansätze, die da derzeit existieren, sind alle halbherzig und gehen alle nicht weit genug.
Also ich hab mir bei meiner jetzt relativ komplizierten Konfiguration, die jetzt auch noch mit diversen anderen SYNKing-Tools zusammengearbeitet, hab ich mir erst mal schön das Adressbuch zerschossen. Also ich hatte dann plötzlich massenhaft Einträge doppelt drin, konnte erst mal alles schön durcharbeiten.
Und was ich, haben wir glaube ich auch schon fünfmal in der Woche geredet, aber ich muss das jetzt nochmal sagen, was ich überhaupt nicht verstehe und was mich maßgeblich davon abhält, mehr als einen Macintosh gleichzeitig zu betreiben und damit zu kaufen, ist, dass ich einfach nicht zwei Macs miteinander synchronisieren kann. Einfach nicht out of the box. Warum? Warum geht das nicht? Das verstehe ich einfach nicht. Und da ist Apple auch vollkommen auf dem falschen Pfad. Dass sie das nicht schnallen. Ich meine, mobile me hin, mobile me her. Das ist immer noch Internet. Und ich will einfach zwei Computer haben. Ich hätte hier gerne einen Desktop-Rechner und einen Laptop. Das würde auch dazu führen, dass ich ganz anders über das Portfolio, was ich kaufe, nachdenke. Jetzt habe ich so einen Kompromiss-Rechner, so ein MacBook. Das ist gerade eben mobil genug, aber auch irgendwie desktopig genug. Eigentlich hätte ich aber lieber so einen Big-Screen-iMac oder noch etwas Größeres. Je nachdem, also was ist der Größte gerade? 24 Zoll?
Keine Ahnung, ob ich sowas...
Genau, 24 Zoll iMac mit irgendwie fett Tralala-Platte und so weiter. Und dann hätte ich gerne noch so einen R.
Weißt du, wie ich das im Augenblick...
Oder was auch immer. Verstehst du, was ich meine? Und dann möchte ich sagen, dieser Verzeichnisbereich oder dieser User, den hätte ich gerne gesynkt. Und zwar ausschließlich dieser Daten, dass ich einfach sowas wie meine Podcasts synken kann. Dass ich die sowohl on the go habe, dass ich mein Telefon sowohl mit dem einen Rechner als auch mit dem anderen synken kann. Und es ist fürs Telefon irgendwie dasselbe. Dass ich den on the road synken kann, dass ich on the road auch mit meinem Rechner irgendwie da Podcasts einspielen kann. Aber vor allem, dass meine Files übergeschert werden und dass meine gesynkt werden. Und eben auch Adressbuch einträge. Dass es egal ist, mit welchem Rechner ich zu welchem Zeitpunkt arbeite. Und zwar auch egal in welcher Software. Und das ist für Programme, das kommt noch dazu. Und das ist ja auch das, was im Zusammenspiel mit dem iPhone noch total fehlt. Dass Programme sich sehr schnell in diese ganze Sync-Geschichte mit einklinken können und sagen, ich will jetzt auch teilnehmen an diesem verteilten Datenspaß. Und dass es für diese akzeptablen Konditionen möglich ist, daran teilzunehmen einschließlich des iPhones. Das fehlt. Ich gäbe es das, ich würde locker mindestens ein Gerät mehr kaufen.
Also ich habe ja nun so ein relativ ähnliches Problem plötzlich gehabt wie du, dass ich nämlich durch dieses MSI, von dem ich ja schon erzählt habe, durch dieses Netbook, wo ich mir Mac OS X draufgespielt habe, habe ich ja plötzlich genau das gleiche Problem, dass ich Daten von einem auf dem anderen Rechner haben will. Und darum habe ich mir auf beiden Systemen Dropbox installiert. Dieses habe ich ja auch schon mal von erzählt. Das ist, wie gesagt, so ein relativ hübsches Tool, mit dem man Daten auf mehreren Rechner synchronisieren kann. Das funktioniert schön im Hintergrund und funktioniert ganz großartig. Und das habe ich jetzt mal genutzt, zuerst mit Eventbox, was mein Twitter-Client ist, nach dem Motto mit Daten, wo es jetzt nicht so dramatisch ist, wenn die wegkommen, indem ich einfach, und das ist jetzt ein bisschen tricky, ich habe den Application Support Ordner von Eventbox, habe ich auf meine Dropbox kopiert, und habe dann in meinem Application Support, also in der Library hat man Application Support, und da gibt es einen Eventbox Ordner, in dem ist die Datenbank drinnen mit den Tweets, und welche davon angekuckt sind. Die habe ich geschoben auf die Dropbox, und alles was ich gemacht habe, ist in den Application Support Ordner einen Symbolik-Link gelegt. Ich weiß nicht, ob es auch mit dem Alias gegangen wäre, aber ich habe dann hinteran einfach auf der Stelle einen Symbolik-Link angelegt, habe das auf beiden Rechnern gemacht, was dazu führt, dass dieser Application Support Ordner über die, also dieser Eventbox Ordner, über Dropbox hin und her geschoben wird. Das funktioniert, also wenn ich jetzt hier auf dem Macbook Pro Eventbox beende, mein Twitter client, werden die Daten hochgespielt, in so Cloud, ich klappe mein MSI auf, da werden sie runtergeladen, dann kann ich Eventbox starten. Das geht natürlich komplett in die Hose, wenn ich auf die dämliche Idee komme, das Eventbox auf dem anderen Rechner dann jeweils zu früh zu starten oder so was. Also ist weit davon entfernt, eine perfekte Lösung zu sein. Aber funktioniert soweit okay. Also so gut, dass ich jetzt überlege, vielleicht mache ich das auch mal mit den Adium Einstellungen. Ist natürlich in jedem Fall Handarbeit und widerlich. Und ein bisschen gefährlich und man sollte vielleicht Backups haben und so was. Aber es ist die bessere, wie gesagt, mit meinen Tweets ist es mir eigentlich relativ wurscht, wenn die dann eben mal ein paar als neue markiert werden, die ich schon gelesen habe, dann sei es drum. Hauptsache ist nicht immer der Fall. Und ich kann mir vorstellen, dass das auch mit iPhone, iTunes Einstellungsdaten, obwohl, nee, damit wird es garantiert nicht funktionieren, weil da geht dann der im komplett in die Hose und das machen sie nicht.
Wollen wir uns mal ein Thema suchen, wo wir wieder mit Dennis reden können?
Was?
Ja, sag mal Dennis.
Syncing ist nicht so mein Ding, weil...
Ich weiß, ich weiß. Musst du nicht rausreden, musst du nicht entschuldigen.
Obwohl damals, bei Pixel Park, da hatten wir so einen Experten irgendwie, also wir hatten ja nur Experten, ne? Und der eine war irgendwie zuständig dafür, dass halt unsere, wir haben auf Sun irgendwie alle da fett geklickert. Und ne, und da hatte ich sogar noch einen Mac. Jedenfalls hatten wir alle Netscape, weil damals war ein Netscape voll das Ding. Und irgendwie, da hat das irgendwie so was, so ein Netscape-Server eingerichtet, oder irgendwie so ein Tool, dass irgendwie ich alle meine Bookmarks immer irgendwie vom Server krieg und auf jedem Rechner, wo ich irgendwie war, kam die.
Das war halt die Vision des...
Und deswegen ist Apple Evil wild, weil eigentlich ist es ein ganz scheiß billig, irgendwie easy-lösbares Problem, aber haben sie gedacht, ist ja easy-lösbar, aber wir wollen den Kunden natürlich fett an uns binden und deswegen gibt es das Feature nur mit Mobile Max, kostet irgendwie 80 Euro im Jahr oder was?
Weil wir dafür zu lazy sind.
Wahrscheinlich. Es muss einfach rein.
Bonjour, Sie haben alle Techniken, keiner kann mir erzählen, dass dieses Problem nicht lösbar ist. Ich meine, wenn Sie das im Internet schaffen, dann können Sie das doch bitte auch in meinem Laden schaffen.
Oder?
Das ist alles bekloppt.
Vielleicht sollten wir uns da was einfallen lassen, weil jeder hat ja eigentlich einen iMap-Mail-Server, eigentlich die Bookmarks einfach in den Mail-Server schieben, per Mail und sich die davon da wieder abholen.
Und wenn Sie der Meinung sind, dass Sie das Peer to Peer nicht hinkriegen können, dann sollen Sie doch bitte einen Apple-Home-Server rausbringen, wo man ordentlich Platten und CFS-Pools dranballern kann.
Und dass man einen VPN für sein iPhone kriegt und alles.
Genau. Wo ich meinen iTunes-Scheiß drauf schmeißen kann.
Du kannst es ja dann noch anmieten, woanders. Kannst du dann bei mir kaufen?
Doch, ich will das zu Hause haben.
Ich will das auch zu Hause haben.
Und dann kann ich auch meine Mailer drauf haben. Ich will einfach alles drauf haben.
Ich will auch gerne einen VPN für mein iPhone zu mir nach Hause haben. Nicht bei irgendwem, sondern mein eigenes.
Das kannst du doch überhaupt machen, oder?
Ich kann das machen, klar. Aber da sitzt erst mal Stunden da und ich hätte es gerne fertig.
Ja, dann geht es wieder nicht nach Update.
Die haben ja ein Produkt, irgendwie OS X Server, sollen sie OS X Home Server rausbringen.
Genau. Und dann kann man darüber halt auch Sünden. Dann ist da der Apple SYNC Server drauf und ab geht's.
iPhone, VPN, IMAP Server, irgendwie keine Ahnung. Also was gibt es noch? Ab vergessen.
Mac OS X Server plus Syncing. Mehr will ich eigentlich gar nicht.
Und Backup und alles.
Und iTunes.
Eigentlich alles. Time Capsule plus Apple TV plus alles in einem kleinen Kasten, der rund um die Uhr läuft.
Das wollen wir. Apple, das zugehört?
Okay.
Genau.
Kommt, haben sie gesagt.
So, und da war jetzt, wir waren mal bei Peer to Peer, oder was hast du gesagt, da war die vollen Experten am Start und dann haben wir auch gleich beim nächsten Thema, Warübergang, Pirate Bay. Ist hier ein ganz großes Thema bei unseren Zuhörern.
Da ging es diese Woche total zur Sache?
Genau, da gibt es den sogenannten Spektrial, weil es mehr ein Spektakel als ein Trial ist. Und da müssen nämlich die Verantwortlichen von Pirate Bay, sind wohl irgendwie vier Leute, die da irgendwie mehr oder weniger mit zu tun haben, müssen sich in Schweden vor Gericht verantworten, ja, wo warst denn eigentlich, ich hab gar nicht so aufgepasst. Du hast nicht aufgepasst, ich dachte, du erzählst mir jetzt alles, weil ich hab keine Zeit für das, weißt du schon.
Du weißt ja nicht, warum sie vor Gericht gehen.
Juristisch muss man nie erzählen, ich will nur die schmutzigen Details haben.
Das sind wohl die Nachwählen von der Hausdurchsuchung, die die da irgendwie, wann war es, also schon mindestens zwei Jahre her, wo sie diese schönen Überwachungsvideos gezeigt haben. Ja, wo sie irgendwie alle Rechner einmal mitgenommen haben und Pirate Bay, wie sagte der Kläger, dass es ja nur drei Tage gedauert hätte, bis es wieder online war und dann hat der eine, Tiamo heißt das, ich gleich verteidige, nee, zweieinhalb wären es nur gewesen. Und in jeden Fall müssen sie sich da gerade, ich weiß nicht, ob man es schon verantworten nennt, aber zumindestens ein bisschen Rede und Antwort stehen und auch werden noch verhört, ich weiß nicht, ob man das als Zeuge vernommen oder irgendwie so. Und es ist wohl aber mehr lustig dort, fast. Aber auch sehr politisch, weil heute wurden wohl ziemlich viele ideologische Fragen gestellt und gar nicht mehr so zum Thema selbst.
Also es geht jetzt seit Anfang der Woche und es läuft noch?
Seit Montag.
Und ja, ich meine, was ist sozusagen bisher da rausgekommen?
Also eigentlich sind die ganzen großen Medienfirmen da hinterher und die meinten, sie haben halt auch eine Schadensersatzklage da am Start und wollten, ich weiß nicht, wie viele Millionen von Dollars oder Kronen oder Euros haben. Und das hat der Richter am Montag aber gleich erst mal weggeschritten und hat gesagt, es ist hier Schweden und wir kümmern uns halt nur um Schweden und sind irgendwie 100.000 Euro oder so übrig geblieben. Alles andere wurde erst mal gleich gecancelt. Am zweiten Tag hat wohl, oder was, am dritten? Ich glaub am zweiten, hat die Anklage irgendwie die ganzen Beschuldigungen zur Hälfte erstmal fallen gelassen.
Also die Anklage ist die Staatsanwaltschaft, die schwedische Staatsanwaltschaft, oder wer?
Weil sie irgendwie alles gar nicht beweisen konnten und jetzt irgendwie nur noch Beihilfe oder irgendwie so übrig geblieben ist. Ich hab gerade noch einen anderen Fallen im Kopf, aber ist egal.
Das hab ich so halt mitbekommen. Also ist es sozusagen grundlegend abgelehnt worden, über die Verbreitung von copyrightgeschütztem Material zu reden, weil sie das nachweislich nicht tun, sondern es geht nur um die Beihilfe zur Verbreitung.
Was ich mit dem nachweislich nicht tun, müssen sie aber gerade auch schon noch so ein bisschen erklären. Da ist irgendwie der Term, wir haben die King Kong Defense aufgetaucht. Und zwar hat ein Verteidiger, ich weiß nicht von wem jetzt, hat gesagt, dass wenn da ein sogenannter theoretischer User King Kong irgendwas runterlädt, dann hat ja einer von den Betreibern mit diesem King Kong keinen direkten Kontakt. Und laut Gesetz muss man, wenn man Beihilfe zu irgendwas leistet, muss man mit dieser Person Kontakt haben. Das heißt, wenn du was runterlädst, und ich dich dabei aber gar nicht, wir uns gar nicht abgesprochen haben, oder wie auch immer, dann habe ich dir keine Beihilfe geleistet. Nur, dass ich dir die technische Möglichkeit stelle, ohne die direkt schon für dich gebaut zu haben. Wenn ich die grundsätzlich zur Verfügung stelle und du die dann nutzt, dann ist es keine Beihilfe, weil wir hatten nie direkt miteinander Kontakt. Das Ding kann man schon bei Wikipedia nachgucken.
Wenn ich eine Autobahn baue und ein Bankräuber fährt drüber, dann ist es keine Beihilfe zum Bankraum.
Außer du hast die Autobahn anscheinend direkt für den Bankräuber nur gebaut. Hast du aber nicht. Und das ist die King Kong Defense.
Verstehe.
Genau.
Die King Kong Defense.
Kann man nachlesen, ist ganz witzig. Nee, ja einfach den...
Naja, das wird sich schon...
Den Userbegriff King Kong haben sie sich irgendwie einfallen lassen.
Ist auf jeden Fall ein schönes Buzzword, ne?
Ja, und dann wurde auch einer von den Machern dann noch gefragt, was er denn, ob er schon mal nach einem Film im Internet oder bei Google gesucht hätte. Und hat halt mit Ja geantwortet. Und dann hat er gefragt, was er denn da gefunden hätte. Und wollte wahrscheinlich schon so ein bisschen drauf hinaus, dass ja Pirate Bay immer ganz oben kommt. Und er hat dann aber ganz locker geantwortet, dass halt...
Internet Movi Database.
Die Internet Movi Database, IMDB, ganz oben kommt. Und hat es auch erstmal für Lacher gesorgt. Und der Prozess wird audio live gestreamt, zum ersten Mal in ganz, also in Schweden.
Das erste...
Das ist der erste Prozess in Schweden, der live gestreamt wird. Und die Akteure dort, weil die nennen es ja Spectre oder auch Soap irgendwie, der Broke P, dieser Peter, der twittert aus dem Gerichtssaal. Und er meint, er ist wahrscheinlich der Erste, der aus dem Gerichtssaal twittert. Als Angeklagte direkt und nicht mal Zuschauer, sondern die sitzen auf der Bank oder wie auch immer und twittern von da.
twitter.com/brokep, ich glaube, der hat schon 5500 Follower, als ich heute geguckt habe.
Unendlich viele, also am ersten Tag.
Peter ist auch wirklich, muss man auch sagen, ich hab ihn ja mal interviewt für Chaos Radio. Und wir kennen ihn ja jetzt auch schon so ein bisschen, weil er häufig hier irgendwie in Berlin war.
Er will auch nach Berlin ziehen.
Echt? Er ist glaube ich der einzige, der überhaupt noch in Schweden ist von dieser ganzen Bande. Also, der ist schon echt cool. Und die sind, überhaupt diese ganze Community, ist wirklich...
Die sind schon...
Die sind wirklich cool im Sinne von cool.
Die sind so locker, dass es fast schon wieder radikal ist.
Das ist echt unglaublich, oder? Wie laid-back die sind, so ach ja, wir sind dann irgendwie mal verklagt worden und irgendwie die CIAs hinter uns her und so. Dann haben die immer so ein Lächeln irgendwie auf dem Gesicht. Und es ist so, was kann uns Besseres passieren?
Das wird ja auch versucht, den zu unterstellen, dass sie halt irgendwie mit Pirate Bay Geld verdienen. Aber auch, als ich die mal irgendwie vor einem Jahr oder so gefragt habe oder letzten Sommer, wie es denn mit der Kohle aussieht, weil der ganze Traffic, den die da verursachen mit ihren Servern und Trackern und so weiter, das muss doch irgendwie ganz schön ins Geld gehen. Ich meinte, ja, wir sind gerade so bei 27.000 Euro miese. Aber ja, ach, das kriegen wir schon wieder hin.
Ach, ich dachte, die würden schon ganz gut davon leben, von den ganzen...
Nee, das kostet glaube ich auch schon eine ganze Menge.
Ich dachte, das kriegen sie lange durch, bei einer Werbung wieder.
Die erzeugen da einen Traffic.
Na ja, eigentlich sollte doch der Traffic relativ gering sein. Dafür ist doch BitTorrent mal entwickelt worden.
Dennis, kannst du noch mal die Statistiken runterbeten?
Na, ich hab mal gefragt und es war 1,2 Gigabit pro Sekunde. Und die Trecker-Rechner alleine sind 8 Stück, die da dauerhaft laufen.
Aber wie viele PIs haben die? Wie viele Werbebanner könnten die theoretisch ausliefern?
Also die Trecker zum Beispiel haben ja keine... Also die laufen einfach so, da klickt ja keiner. Das sind einfach 8 Rechner, die schon mal keine Werbung haben und laufen müssen und Traffic verbrauchen und nichts einnehmen.
Naja, aber viele gehen auch über ein Web-Interface.
Aber natürlich gibt es die ganzen Torrents auch irgendwie wieder. Bei Isohunt und bei 100.000 anderen. Okay, die haben natürlich irgendwie, die sind irgendwie Platz 200 oder 191 der weltweit meistbesuchten Websites oder sowas. Also da wird schon ordentlich geklickt.
Das ist ein Vergleich zu dem eigentlichen Traffic, der durch das Trecken erzeugt wird.
Auch keine Quality-Bewerbung, die die da haben. Also ich glaube, da gibt es nicht wirklich viel Geld für. Es ist nicht so, dass die da Spiegel werben, sondern es ist halt nur Pirate Pay.
Ich dachte, dass das schon reicht, um da wenigstens ein gewisses Plus rauszuhandeln.
Na, reich muss es ja, sonst könnten sie es nicht mehr machen. Also, das wird es schon sein. Aber ich glaube, reich wird man auch nicht. Und die Rechner, die sie andauernd kaufen müssen, jetzt gab es erst wieder neue Trecker-Rechner.
Das Ding ist auch, was ich auch faszinierend fand, ist so, ich hab da jetzt eine sehr distante Kenntnis davon. Also, es ist unser Ferneindruck aus mehreren Kontakten über die Jahre. Die sind halt cool, so. Und was ich aber noch viel wichtiger finde, ist, die meinen es auch so. Also, die sind einfach die Piratenbucht. Die sehen, also, die machen das auch nicht mit so einem Lächeln im Sinne von ha ha ha, wir sind jetzt hier irgendwie die coolen Wears-Dudes, aber wir lassen uns nicht kriegen. Das ist nicht der Punkt. Sondern die haben diese Ideologie des freien Verteilens von Daten und des freien Zugänglichmachen von Kulturgut, das wohnt in ihnen. Also, das ist wirklich das, worum es denen da auch geht. Und das ist so das Faszinierende. Und ich glaube, dass die da auch als Gruppe da eine ganze Menge Power draus ziehen. Ich meine, allein die Tatsache, dass sie es bis in eine Parteienstruktur geschafft haben. Ich meine, das sind alles nochmal so disjunkte Organisationen. Und die sind auch in gewisser Hinsicht disjunkt. Das ist jetzt nicht nur so, dass sie so verschiedene Tarnabteilungen haben, sondern das sind einfach, jeder kümmert sich da so ein bisschen um was anderes. Klar, die kennen sich in die Reisen auch. Letztendlich ziehen die auch alle irgendwie an einem Strang. Aber jeder hat halt andere Mittel. Pirate Bay macht halt was Pirate Bay macht. Und die Piratpartie macht halt das. Und das Anti-Gruppierbüro ist halt irgendwie auch nochmal auf einer anderen Ebene unterwegs. Also das ist fasziniert. Also ich finde es wirklich faszinierend. Ich würde mich super freuen, wenn der Peter nach Berlin kommt. Ja, fein.
Jedenfalls kann man da weiter beobachten, was da so abgeht in Schweden. Weil der internationale Druck auf Schweden ist natürlich auch nicht gering.
Das kann man wohl sagen. Aber die Schweden, das muss man nochmal dazusehen. Warum Schweden gerade so interessant ist, ist mir auch erst durch irgendeinen Bericht klar geworden. Die Schweden, es geht ja vor allem auch um Musik. Und bei Musik, da kennen die Schweden keinen Spaß. Weil, machen wir uns mal kurz klar, Schweden und Musik. Aber? Ja, es ist nicht nur aber, sondern seit, aber und auch schon vorher. Das sind die Schweden, die die Popmusik machen auf diesem Planeten. Und die Amerikaner lassen sich das von den Schweden quasi schreiben und machen dann ihre Cover-Versionen. Die können das dann besser vermarkten und das ist dann sozusagen die amerikanische Produktion, die bekannt wird. Ich meine jetzt mal so Hip-Hop, Rap und so weiter, lasse ich jetzt mal außen vor. Popmusik. Schweden ist so die Produktionszentrale für Popmusik. Und die Schweden haben da einfach auch so diese Sicht drauf. Das haben wir doch sowieso alles erfunden. Was wollt ihr eigentlich? Ja, ihr Amerikaner, ihr wollt jetzt hier irgendwie unsere Prioraten platt machen? Habt ihr sie noch alle? Die Musik habt ihr sowieso vorher von uns geklaut. Jetzt dürfen wir das auch zurückklauen. Das ist jetzt nicht eine juristische Argumentation. Ich meine nur, wie das so in einem Teil der Bevölkerung auch verankert ist.
Meinst du das ist so?
Ja, das ist so, als würden die Amerikaner überhaupt das Auto erfunden. Was glaubst du, wie populär das in Deutschland wäre?
Stille.
Schock.
Moment.
Ich hab dir eine Frage gestellt, ich hab die in der Zeit Twitter gelesen.
Gut, wollen wir zur Gerüchteküche vorspulen? Es gibt eine. Also es gibt auch Belege. Und zwar, also ich will jetzt nicht über Mcmini reden und diese komischen Fotos, die da gekommen sind. Ich glaub, das können wir uns sparen. Ich mein, wenn der so käme, würde ich ihn sofort so kaufen, weil das ist genau das, was ich brauche, so mit zwei Virausgängen und so. Aber Apple Store. Es soll Apple Store kommen nach Hamburg.
Warum nicht nach Berlin?
Na, weil in Berlin keiner Kohle hat.
Und in Hamburg oder was?
Naja, bitte dich, da wohnen die meisten Millionäre in Deutschland.
Ja. Und ich dachte, da gibt's nur besoffene Matrosen.
Abstand, da wohnen mehr Millionäre als im Rest von Deutschland zusammen.
Ich glaube, die höchste Millionärsdichte hat aber, wie heißt das, in der Nähe von?
Blankenese.
Nee, nicht Blankenese. Nee, nee. Da, wo Bertelsmann sitzt, in dem Kaff, wie heißt denn das?
Gütersloh.
Gütersloh. Das glaube ich die höchste Millionärsdichte angeblich in Deutschland.
Ach.
Also eigentlich müsste da der App ist, dahin.
Gibt es in der Wikipedia schon Liste der Millionäre in Deutschland? Ressourcen gibt es ja, die Frage, wo ist so am meisten, wie auch immer. Tatsache ist, Hamburg hat Geld. So. Ja, und das ist auf jeden Fall, ich meine, die werden wahrscheinlich Münkebergstraße oder sowas oder an einer Alts-, innenalzer, irgendwie so in dem Bereich, schütze ich mal irgendwo in der City, werden die sich da eine Location ausgraben und es ist derzeit noch vollkommen unklar, wohin das kommt. Keine Ahnung, was derzeit wirklich jetzt als der High-End-Traffic-Bereich gilt. Ich hab so Münkebergstraße immer so im Kopf, weiß nicht, ob das noch gilt, irgendwo da. Und dann werden sie das halt aufmachen. Und in Berlin ist halt einfach mal so, ich meine, was hast du hier in Berlin? Hast du arme Studenten, Punks? Und nerds, die irgendwie kein Geld ausgeben.
Und Schwaben.
Jetzt kommen wir nicht damit wieder.
Ich hab da mein Türk an der Ecke. Ich kann da nicht so gut.
Nee, überhaupt nicht. Da fangen wir jetzt auch nicht mit an.
Außerdem gibt es hier einen Graves, der ist ja gar nicht so schlecht. Hab ich schon mal erwähnt, wie...
Ja, der mag vielleicht nicht schlecht sein, aber du weißt schon, kannst du mal mit diesem Stift... Du weißt schon, was der Unterschied ist.
Ich war noch nie in einem echten.
Du warst noch nie in einem Applestore.
Ich war noch nie.
Das hatten wir glaube ich auch schon mal, oder?
Siehst du, ich hab's noch nie bis nach München geschafft, aber der ist noch nicht mal bis zum Erster Platz.
Du warst noch nicht mal im Gravis?
Nicht in den letzten x Jahren, also viele, viele.
Also auch den neuen großen Gravis-Store in Berlin, den kennst du gar nicht.
Aber ich war bei Cyberport und jetzt darf ich mir abrenten, das ist ja voll die Rant-Sendung hier, oder? Weil bei Cyberport, also ich hab ja meine Platte da gekauft, die dicke große.
Die haben einen Laden oder was?
Ist sogar voll geil.
Ich glaub, das war früher mal Cassandra oder so.
Echt, da hab ich mal gearbeitet, ist egal. Bei Cyber-Store-Dingens kannst du, also du musst ewig warten, das ist jetzt mein Rant. Also du gehst hin und dann stehen die da und dann fummeln die und dann müssen die hinten ins Lager rennen, müssen Zeug holen und dann basteln sie und dann haben die Mac-Kunden ja auch alle keinen Plan, wahrscheinlich alle Computernutzer. Und dann stellen die eine Frage und dann müssen die erst mal labern und die Angestelltenverkäufer haben natürlich auch nur noch gefährliches Halbwissen. Ich hoffe, jetzt hört keiner zu, aber es sind halt keine Techniker, es sind halt Verkäufer.
Hier hört niemand zu, der was mit Macintosh zu tun hat, Dennis.
Wahrscheinlich. Wenn ich das dann Cyberportverkäufer weiß, ich muss nächstes anonyme einkaufen, ist egal.
Kaufst du bisher unanonym ein? Sagst du mal, hallo, ich bin Dennis von MobileMax, mach mir einen guten Preis?
Nein, das dauert alles ewig. Aber man kann ja im Cyberport Store, wie auch immer, man kann da irgendwie anrufen oder online irgendwie sich was bestellen lassen. Die sagen dann, wann es da ist und dann gibt es da nämlich einen Express-Schalter. Dann gehst du da hin und kannst es direkt abholen. Da muss man nicht lange warten. Aber wenn du direkt so reingehst, das kann ewig dauern.
Und das ist genau der Unterschied zwischen einem Apple Store und allen anderen Mac-Läden. Du kommst da rein und du wirst erschlagen von der Zahl von Mitarbeitern. Also da sind einfach gefühlt dreimal so viele Leute, wie du meinst, wie du Saladen eigentlich haben wirst. Das ist unfassbar. Du hast immer sofort einen an der Backe. Du stehst da keine 10 Sekunden rum, bevor du nicht gefragt wirst.
Du gehst in einen Laden, guckst dir die Klamotten an, da steht gleich einer neben dir und fragt, du fühlst dich beobachtet?
Ja, aber die sind so gut geschult, dass es, also da mag es jetzt auch mal einen Ausreißer geben oder so, aber ich war jetzt schon in mehreren Apple Stores. Ich war in London, ich war in Toronto, ich war fast in Glasgow.
Und in jedem hast du alle Verkäufe und ich war in München.
Ja, ich hab immer eine Frage gefunden, die mir keiner beantworten konnte, aber sie waren immer auf eine ganz professionelle Art und Weise. Das ist wirklich erstaunlich. Und dass sie das auch in Deutschland geschafft haben, das muss ich hoch anrechnen, weil du weißt, wie das ist mit der deutschen Service-Mentalität. Irgendwie haben sie die gebrochen. Also ich glaube, die müssen auch alle nach Cupertino. Die gehen da so durch so einen totalen Durchblickstrudel. Ich denke, die haben so ungefähr so einen 200 Meter langen Tunnel gebaut, wo sie diese ganzen Apple Store-Mitarbeiter so lämmen da so rein aus einem Fließband, laufen die da so durch und dann kriegen die, glaube ich, so für mehrere Stunden Projektionen und Steve Jobs Keynotes und so eine Sachen. Aber auch eine ganze Menge Wissen vermittelt.
Wie bei Dr. No, wo sie von den radioaktiven Zeug befreit werden, weil sie dann auch so lang gefahren und geschruppt und gesäubert und so mit Ursula Andres?
Ja, Laserstrahlen, also ich würde mir da so einiges vorstellen. Magnetfelder und so, vielleicht auch so ein bisschen Antigravität. Dass die so einfach auch mal so 10 Minuten ohne Schwerkraft einfach so durch vielleicht so schräg nach oben fliegen oder so. Irgendwie machen die das, auf jeden Fall sind die nett. Ist doch mal eine Theorie, oder?
Das braucht man, um netten Deutschen hinzukriegen.
Im Service-Bereich eines Ladens, ich bitte, in Berlin? Ich meine, okay, München, ich weiß nicht, wie die Realität in Berlin ist. In München ist normalerweise, es ist jetzt nicht so sehr viel besser als in Berlin. In Berlin, wenn Apple in Berlin es schafft, einen Laden aufzumachen und ich bin da eine Viertelstunde und alle sind scheiße freundlich, und zwar auf eine Art und Weise, wo ich nicht das Gefühl habe, ich bin bei Walmart. Also nicht so eine Walmart-scheiße freundliche Nummer.
Ich war noch nie bei Walmart.
Das ist halt noch mal eine ganz andere Geschichte, die fass mal jetzt nicht auf. Aber du weißt etwa, was ich meine. Also Leute, die die ganze Zeit so excited sind und sind irgendwie I love this company mäßig. Steve Ballmer-Style.
Dann freust du dich ganz herzlich.
Ja und dann um die Haare. Schön, dass sie hier gewesen sind. Du wolltest das fast nicht aufmachen. Na ja, wie auch immer. Das fast ist nicht ganz so. Ich hab nur kurz reingeguckt. Wenn sie das schaffen, dann kaufe ich irgendwie so ein Produkt mit einem dreistelligen Kaufbetrag. Einfach nur so. Egal ob ich es brauche oder nicht.
Okay.
Das wird ein Rat.
Sag mir vorher Bescheid, dann nimmst du einfach eins, was ich brauchen kann. Ich bin ja begeistert davon. Ich habe mir mein MacBook damals bei Gravis gekauft, wegen der Garantie, die die haben. Die haben ja so eine Garantieverlängerung. Wenn man bei Apple so eine Garantieverlängerung kauft, dann zahlt man ja für 300 Euro für so ein MacBook, wenn mich nicht alles täuscht, oder für ein MacBook Pro. Also auf jeden Fall ziemlich ein Batzen Geld. Und das bietet Gravis ein bisschen günstiger an. Und zwar, ich glaube, für ein MacBook Pro so knapp 100 Euro. Genau, wenn man den Rechner kauft, dann hat man eben statt einem Jahr 3 Jahre Garantie. Die letzten 2 Jahre davon von Gravis.
Gravis-Garantie?
Kehr, glaube ich. Und das habe ich damals bei meinem MacBook Pro dazugekauft. Und prompt natürlich nach Ablauf der Garantiezeit fing mein Display an, plötzlich Probleme zu machen. Und dann habe ich das jetzt Anfang des Jahres mal hingebracht, habe ja auch von erzählt. Davon war ich sehr beeindruckt. Also ich habe am Tag vorher auf der Webseite habe ich mir einen Termin geben lassen bei einem Techniker. Bin dann hin, war eine Viertelstunde zu spät, weil die Bahn nicht ganz so geklappt hat, wie ich mir das vorgestellt hatte. Auf jeden Fall stand da einer, ach komm, nach vorne hier ist kein Problem. Bin nach vorne gegangen, habe meinen Rechner aufgeklappt, habe gezeigt, was das Problem ist. Während er mit mir sprach, hat er den Akku ausgebaut, hat die Seriennummer eingelesen, hat gesagt, alles klar, Display austauschen, klar, Garantiefall, überhaupt keine Frage. Ich musste keine Rechnung vorzeigen, gar nichts. Stimmt die Telefonnummer noch, damit wir uns bei dir melden können? Hat mir meine Telefonnummer vorgelesen, die ich offensichtlich beim Kauf angegeben hatte. War alles kein Problem, hat das Ding mitgenommen, ich war keine drei Minuten später wieder draußen. Oder direkt bei Schäuble weiß der Teufel was.
Ich habe neulich so eine SMS von Google mitgebracht, das hat mich wirklich ein bisschen beunruhigt.
Ich mache mal kurz fertig, dann kannst du es erzählen. Und dann haben die mich eine Woche später angerufen, ja hallo, Ihr Macbook Pro ist fertig, bin ich wieder hingegangen, hab mir mein Macbook Pro ausgewechselt, abgeholt. Und das ist jetzt, die haben nicht einfach nur das Display ausgetauscht. Also ich hab schon mal, ich hab mal ein kaputtes Powerbook gehabt. Da haben die das Display ausgetauscht, da war dann hier der Apple, der hatte dann hier oben so eine braune Stelle. Und zwar ist das wohl so eine relativ übliche Sache, auf dem Display sind nämlich so Aufkleber drauf. Und die muss man eigentlich abziehen, bevor man das einbaut. Weil das ist genau an der Stelle immer gewesen, wo der Apfel ist, das kenn ich von so vielen Leuten, die das gehabt haben. Dass sie das gerne drauflassen und dass man irgendwelche Macken hat, wenn man das Ding aus der Reparatur zurückholt. Und die haben einfach komplett den gesamten Deckel oben ausgewechselt. Und das Ding ist wie neu. Das hält bestimmt jetzt normalen Jahr mindestens, oder anderthalb. Und jeder, der mal in so einer Apple-Preisliste gesehen hat, was so ein scheiß Display kostete, der ahnt, dass sich dieses Garantieding für mich jetzt wirklich so was von gelohnt hat gerade. Und das war absolut stressfrei.
Ich kenne auch nur solche Berichte, muss ich sagen. Ich dachte ja am Anfang, das wäre so ein bisschen hier so die...
So Abzocke, so ja, ja, das funktioniert.
Naja, so ein bisschen so die Aldi-Variante und dann musst du da noch groß diskutieren, aber das scheint nicht der Fall zu sein. Du kriegst da irgendwie korrektes Replacement. Bei dem MacBook, wo ich das auch selber begleitet habe, war das ähnlich. Also da wurde sozusagen, da war es sogar noch ein bisschen absurder. Da haben wir das abgegeben und der offensichtlichste Defekt war Gehäuseabsplitterung und so weiter, so der Klassiker bei so MacBook. Und noch irgendwas. Und dann hatte ich ganz, also ich weiß gar nicht warum, ich hab's irgendwie nicht zur Sprache gebracht, ich hab's verdrängt oder so. Der Akku war halt so völlig im Arsch. Aber das Ding kam halt zurück und hatte einen nie genannten neuen Akku drin mit dem Kommentar. Na ja, den haben wir getestet, der war irgendwie schwächer als die Polizei erlaubt. Und dann haben wir da einen neuen reingetan. Und das, da muss ich auch sagen, wobei ich weiß jetzt nicht genau, inwieweit das ein Ding von Gravis ist oder von Apple. Weil mir erscheint es so, dass das schon letzten Endes die Garantie ist, die Apple gegenüber ihren Händlern sozusagen durchreicht. Dass sozusagen dieser Serviceplan etwas ist, was eben auch ein Händler bei Apple sozusagen AppleCare für die Händler.
Ja, aber meinst du nicht, dann würde es nicht einen kleinen Händler geben, der das auch zu einem sau günstigen Preis anbietet? Also ich meine, ich würde ja nicht zu Gravis rein, ich würde ja zu Fuchs rein, wenn...
Naja, das tut ja Gravis. Und ich meine Gravis ist die eigentlichen, einzige nennenswerte Meck-Kette, die deutschlandweit agiert.
Ich glaube, die reparieren die Dinger tatsächlich selber, habe ich das Gefühl.
Also das kann gut sein, aber am Ende des Tages müssen sie sich das auch irgendwie bei Apple holen und gibt es natürlich auch legitime Garantieansprüche. Ich weiß es nicht. Keine Ahnung. Falls da jemand belastbare Informationen hat, würde uns auch mal sehr interessieren, inwieweit das jetzt eine reine Gravis-Geschichte ist oder inwieweit sie da letzten Endes auch hintenrum an dem selben Zuverlässigkeitstopp von Apple mit dransitzen. Keine Ahnung. Auf jeden Fall, diese Gravis-Versicherung ist kein schlechter Deal.
Das kann man festhalten. Also meine Erfahrungen bisher mit dem sind besser als das, was ich von Apple in der Garantiezeit erlebt habe.
Und ich würde auch noch nicht sagen, nur weil sie jetzt im Apple Store so besonders nett sind, dass die Gravis-Mitarbeiter nicht versuchen nett zu sein.
Versuchen.
Sie schafft das.
Sie haben sich stets bemüht.
Sie bemühen sich.
Also in dem Fall muss ich wirklich sagen, ich bin...
Den Eindruck hab ich. Ich meine, das ist ja auch... Du hast mal bei Cassandra gearbeitet. Hinten oder vorne? Ich meine, hast du mit Kunden geredet oder hast du geschraubt?
Erst vorne, dann hinten, dann gar nicht mehr.
Erst vorne, dann bist du nach hinten gegangen und haben sie dich weggeschickt.
Ach, ist eine lange Geschichte, aber ich war eher nach hinten dann. Habe ich jemand?
Es war schlimm.
Du hast sie beschimpft.
Nee.
Wann dann?
Ich habe Krampfs nicht klar.
Die Wahrheit gesagt.
Über wen, über die Kunden oder über die Geräte?
Beides.
Dennis, das ist Wirtschaft, da sagt man nicht die Wahrheit.
Aber sie haben zwei Leute gleichzeitig eingestellt, mich und noch so ein Andere. Und der Andere, habe ich gefragt, was der da privat auch meckert, meint er, er hat einen PC und so, und habe ich mich mit dem unterhalten und so weiter und so fort. Und irgendwie kam er über Platten-Speed zu reden, das ist jetzt eine kleine Anekdote. Jedenfalls meint er, so eine aktuelle PC-Festplatte würde 60 Megabyte die Sekunde schaffen. Und wir reden jetzt so von 1995.
60 Megabyte pro Sekunde, 1995.
Also er hat die ganze Platte in einer halben Sekunde gelesen.
Das SCSI normal, Fast SCSI, 10 Megabyte mehr geht gar nicht. Und damals gab es so für Normal-User nichts anderes. 7500, da kamen gerade raus, Power PC. Und dann meinte ich, rein technisch, das geht gar nicht. Dann meinte er, doch, haben die getestet, so eine Zeitschrift, Chip oder was auch immer. Dann meinte ich, haben die das falsch gemacht? Nein, das ist doch eine Zeitschrift, das muss stimmen. Also er hatte immer null Plan, aber der ist da geblieben. Aber der konnte wahrscheinlich den Leuten besser Zeug aufquatschen, weil er war auch von der Chip ja ganz überzeugt. Und ich war irgendwie zu ehrlich, wahrscheinlich.
Das kann gut sein.
Na, ich war da glaube ich vier Wochen oder so.
Gut, worauf ich eigentlich hinaus wollte, ist, wie einfach das ist, die Ruhe zu bewahren, wenn so Kunden Allüren an den Tag legen.
Was nochmal?
Wenn Kunden, ich meine, mal ehrlich, die kommen da alle reinmarschieren und die wissen wahrscheinlich so 10%, die wissen eh alles besser. Ja, damit kann ich nicht sein und so weiter.
Da muss ich dir leider...
Genau, deswegen musst du nach hinten fallen. Jetzt ist die Frage, wie machst du einen Laden, wo du Leute so ausbildest, dass sie das immer ertragen? Weil das erfordert wirklich eine hohe soziale Gabe, dich von irgendeinem Trottel anschreien zu lassen, von dem du genau weißt, dass er einfach nur Dünnpfiff erzählt. Du musst ihn aber trotzdem ehren.
Also mit richtig gutem Lohn, glaube ich, würde ich es eine Weile hinkriegen.
Ich glaube, dass die Apple Store-Mitarbeiter sehr gut bezahlt werden. Ich hab da nur mal was aus London gehört und er hat mir keine Zahlen gesagt, weil er nicht durfte, aber er meinte, so gut habe er noch nie verdient und er wäre sehr zufrieden.
Und Verkäufer kriegen eigentlich nicht so viel Geld, oder?
Ist nicht unbedingt so die klassische Domäne und vor allem ist er auch so bei so vielen. Also die sind wirklich echt overstafft, das ist unfassbar. In Toronto, dieser Apple Store, das ist wirklich so ein kleiner Laden. Keine Ahnung, kann ich so einen Quadratmeter nicht ausdrücken, aber jetzt nicht so ein riesen mehrere Etagen Store, sondern das ist nur so unser Shopping Mall, so ein Loch und das geht da vielleicht so 15 Meter rein und ist irgendwie 10 Meter breit oder so. 20 Meter mal 10 irgendwie so was. Das heißt links und rechts ein paar Tische und das war's. Und da laufen irgendwie 20 Meter weiter rum. Und die Quellen geradezu auch aus diesem Laden heraus.
Hast du letztens so einen Bericht über KDW im Spiegel? Fällt mir gerade an, weiß nicht, wie viele Leute im KDW arbeiten. Ich hab auch gestaunt und konnte es mir gar nicht vorstellen.
Das sind bestimmt sehr viele, weil da ist es nämlich auch ähnlich. Schätz mal KDW, warte mal, da muss ich mal drüber nachdenken. Was haben die da so? Fünf Etagen? Und die sind ganz schön lang. Also, das ist auf jeden Fall eine vierstellige Zahl, würde ich sagen. 1000?
2000. Ich hab mal überlegt. Ich meine, bei fünf Etagen sind es immer noch 400 Leute pro Etage. Okay, hast du auch noch einen Keller, mit Feinschmeckabteilung im Keller, oder?
Nee, die ist oben.
Ganz oben jetzt? Also, ganz, ganz früher war sie ganz unten. Ich war auch schon ganz lange nicht mehr am KDW.
Oh, ist sehr lecker.
Na, ich weiß, siehst du, also soll gut sein.
Jaja, das ist Deluxe. Das ist ja eigentlich so im Prinzip so, die Apple Store ist so KDW für Kumpel. Das ist so, als hättest du die KDW-Abteilung, naja, wobei, gut, das lässt sich jetzt reichen, weil wenn ich mir die Apple-Nische im KDW anschaue, das ist eigentlich traurig. Da steht halt, also steht was, aber das ist nicht nennenswert.
Wo wir gerade bei Verkaufserfahrungen sind, ich war ja mal früher bei Pandasoft, falls sich noch jemand daran erinnern kann. Du warst bei Pandasoft.
Das ist ja aber auch Cassandra, oder?
Cassandra gehörte Pandasoft.
Cassandra wurde von Pandasoft aufgekauft.
Kaltere Augusta, Ali?
Nee, ich war, wie hieß die Straße in Charlottenburg? Wie hieß die Straße jetzt gleich? Also im Hauptgeschäft von Pandasoft.
Ja, ich weiß schon.
Mittlerweile darf man es ja erzählen, weil hier sind ja alle Pleite.
Da war ein Steinplatz um die Ecke, wie hieß die Straße, verdammt. Ich schau mal kurz nach.
Unglaublich, was ist das?
Aber jetzt weiß ich wieder, warum ich nicht mehr bei Cassandra bin.
Das ist Ulanstraße, genau.
Bestimmt, also ich hab die halbe Fritz-Bediegschaft bedient. Fritz? Radio Fritz, Sender.
Die hatten ja nur Windows 3.11.
Ja, aber die Mitarbeiter hatten alle Mac. Und ich hab dann Webcams verkauft. War immer lustig, wenn man die Leute an einer Stimme erkannte.
Okay. Ach so, hast du deinen Johnny kennengelernt oder was?
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee. Johnny hab ich da glaub ich nie gesehen. Aber wie hieß der mit der langen Rille, der nachts immer die Sendung gemacht hat?
der langen Rille?
Nee, der hat immer so die lange Rille gemacht. Den kann ich an den Namen nicht mehr erinnern.
Okay, wie auch immer. Ulanstraße.
In der Ulanstraße. Und da gab's Architekten, die komplett in Schwarz gekleidet waren, mit kahlrasierter Glatze, die dann mit einem rosanen Eyebook damals diese Kleimshell-Dinger rausmarschiert sind. Wir hatten Kunden, die einmal die Woche reingekommen sind und irgendwas für 1000 Mark gekauft haben. Nur, um es dann im Laden aufzureißen, dann musste immer irgendjemand also wirklich nicht aufzumachen, sondern aufzureißen, sodass man am Ende mit einem Staubsauger die Schnipsel wegmachen musste. Wir hatten Leute, die egal bei welchen Problemen, und zwar ich hab mich vertippt, ich krieg die Zeichen nicht wieder weg, mit dem G4 ankamen, den auf den Schreibtestellen und sagten, das muss in 3 Stunden gelöst sein, dann komm ich wieder. Seitdem mag ich Architekt nicht mehr. Die waren nämlich direkt von der TU nebenan das Architekturdepartement. Die hatten dann irgendwelche Powerbooks, und damals war USB ganz neu. Für die USB gab es diese schicken, hellblauen, durchsichtigen Tastaturen, und die wollten dann unbedingt wie ihre Kollegen auch an ihren Powerbooks blaue Tastaturen dran haben, die allerdings nur ADB hatten. Und ich kann mich noch daran erinnern, an eine halbstündige, einem Kunden, dass es, er wollte mir nicht glauben, dass es einfach technisch nicht möglich ist. Es gab damals wirklich keine technische Lösung. Ich hätte ihm ja eine PCMCA-Karte für USB verkauft, aber die gab es zu diesem Zeitpunkt einfach noch nicht. Und es ging nicht in seinen Schädel rein, dass ich ihm nicht irgendwie seine blaue Tastature nicht gönne. Das ist dann so, kann ich mal mit der Geschäftsführung sprechen? Und dann kommt die Geschäftsführung und sagt, geht nicht. Der Kollege hat recht. Ja, es ist aber schon einiges an Geduld. Und dich hab ich da bestimmt auch mal gesehen.
Also ich war da häufig. Ich war ja auch in der Firma der Mac-Admin. Und da hab ich da immer die ganzen Geräte rein und rausgetragen. Wir haben da auf jeden Fall vielleicht nicht jede Woche was für 1000 Euro gekauft, aber da kam schon...
Also ich hab da so teilweise komplette... Und ein bisschen zugrunde gegangen ist der Laden dann daran, dass man pro Kauf irgendwann offiziell noch drei Minuten Zeit hat und dann auch angezählt worden ist, wenn es länger dauerte. Und da waren Leute dabei, die wollten ein Tonstudio zusammenstellen. Die haben gesagt, hallo, hier habe ich eine Million. Ich brauch ein vernünftiges Tonstudio.
Was für ein Laden, Herr Wiesen, weil sie zu lange...
Und dann wurde angezählt, weil man jetzt noch... Zu viert natürlich dann vor denen stand, weil das ist dann ein Bereich, in dem wirklich keiner mehr Ahnung hat. Und ja, das war damals nicht ganz so toll. Und Panasoft, ich glaube, die waren der erste Apple-Händler in Deutschland überhaupt. Also eigentlich ist es eine echte Schande, dass die pleite gegangen sind. Wollten immer eine Markt günstiger sein als Gravis. Hat nicht geklappt. Und das in der Ecke mit der höchsten Millionärstichte in ganz Berlin wahrscheinlich.
Da hätten wir auch nur Qualitätsverkäufer mit voll PC wissen.
Also ich habe auch lange Zeit darunter gelitten, dass eigentlich so Buden, die irgendwie McIntosh verkaufen, und auch wirklich nur so diese McIntosh-Sicht haben und dann irgendwie auch so den Rest der ganzen Technologie nicht sehen. Ich meine, das wird mehr oder weniger zu Recht generell allen vorgeworfen. Uns auch. Und mir einen besonderen, was nur teilweise stimmt. Und das ist dann bei so Händlern nochmal besonders extrem. Na, da haben wir ja mal schöne Geschichten zu erzählen gehabt hier, ne? Jetzt muss ich mal wieder ein paar Haken hier setzen. Oh Gott, wir wurden nochmal nach unseren Home-Stories befragt. Das hatten wir glaube ich schon mal, ne?
Na, ich hab halt bei Cassandra...
Deinen ersten Mac gekauft.
Genau.
Und das war ein...
PowerPC 7500.
So spät erst? Unglaublich.
Ende 95, ja.
Ich hab nicht selber gekauft, ich war viel zu jung. Mein Vater hat einen Mac LC uns hingestellt. Und ich glaube, der erste Computer, den ich überhaupt gesehen habe, war ein Mac SE. Das war wirklich Liebe auf den ersten Blick.
SE oder SE30?
Das ist eigentlich eine lustige Geschichte, weil das war ein DDR SE. Die haben die auch nachgebaut? Nee, die haben die nicht nachgebaut. War so groß wie so ein Wohnzimmer.
Robotron Spezialelektronik.
Es gab ja mal diesen Apple-Werbespot, dass PowerMax G4 nicht in bestimmte Länder exportiert werden durften, weil sie zu schnell waren und zum Bau eines Atomkraftwerkes reichten. Theoretisch. Und die Zeit gab es schon vorher schon mal. Das war so Ende der 80er. Und da durfte alles, was besser war als ein 68000er, der nicht exportiert werden in die Ostzone. Und mein Vater arbeitete in Hamburg. Das ist so ein physikalisches Forschungsinstitut. Die haben nun mal an Max gearbeitet. Und darum musste jetzt irgendwas auch in den Osten rühren. Und darum ein SE. Und die haben dann irgendwie über diesen PDA-Anschluss, Quatsch, wie hießen der? PDS-Slot. Wo man direkt auf den Prozessor zugreifen kann, hatten die dann so ein halbes neues Motherboard unten drunter geklatscht. Ich weiß aber nicht wofür das gut war, aber auf jeden Fall hat er da noch mal einen separaten Reset-Button gehabt. Und es wird mich nicht wundern, wenn da dann unten der 6820 noch hinten dran hing oder der Co-Prozessor oder weißte-weißte-weiß was. Also das war wirklich... Und die haben auch... Da war ein selbstgebasteltes Mousepad dran, weil natürlich wurde das Gerät dann in den Osten geliefert und war kein Mousepad mit dabei. Und kriegt man in der DDR ein Mousepad.
Was heißt denn selbstgemacht, so gehäkelt oder was?
Das war dann irgendwie so eine Stoff-Uhrfläche und die waren irgendwo aufgeklebt. Das war dann so schön rund gemacht. Und damit das so halbwegs nicht kommt von der Konsistenz, kannst du ja nicht einfach Teppichboden nehmen. Das ist ja gar nicht so leicht.
Warum nicht?
Das war mein erster Mac. Eigentlich ganz lustig.
Mein erster Mac war ein Macintosh II CE.
The best Mac ever.
The best Mac ever, genau. Wobei neulich gab es...
Diese riesengroße Kisse?
Nein, das C war für kompakt. Das war eine etwas kleinere Kiste.
Ach, das war, was ich meine, das CX oder wie hießen die?
Der CX und der CE hatten das selbe Gehäuse. Der CX war die langsame Variante, der CE war der schnelle. Und der CE hatte 25 MHz, 68.020, 30 mit 3 Nubus-Slots. Und vor allem diesen coolen Deckel oben, wo du immer so eben kantig... Also hinten eine Schraube lösen, die konnte man eigentlich auch dauerhaft rauslassen, weil der Deckel so draufschnappte.
Die fehlte doch eigentlich sowieso bei alten, oder?
Die war dann irgendwann weg. Und dann macht sie einfach oben den Deckel auf, also so Monitor runterstellen, Deckel hoch.
So wie diese 475 Performa oder was?
Die Pizza Box.
Nee, so klein war die nicht.
Der hatte schon so eine signifikante Höhe. Der war so... was weiß ich.
Der Quadra 700 war ein hochkantgestelltes CI-Gehäuser. Der Quadra 700 war mein Lieblings-Alt-Mac.
Der Quadra 700 war so schön monolithenmäßig. Voll toll, hatte ich eine Weile lang als Router zu Hause mit Modeln.
Naja, wie auch immer. Aber das war auf jeden Fall... Ich hab damals, glaub ich, 10.000 Mark investiert in den Mac und einen Laserdrucker. Das haben wir schon mal erzählt, alles.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Ich bin vom Klondike.
Lange, lange Zeit später.
Haben wir dann noch Themen?
Ja, jetzt hören uns die ganzen Junghörer zu und denken sich nur so...
Die Opa ist schon wieder nicht interessiert, kein Schwein.
Die haben nichts Besseres zu erzählen, sie sind nicht mehr interessiert in der Scheiße. Neunziger Jahre, kein Internet, get real! Also reden wir über neue Scheiße. Ich hab heute neue Scheiße zur Kenntnis genommen und ich bin ein bisschen nervös. Ich hab ein bisschen lasse Hände. Ich war heute bei Ableton. Du weißt schon?
Das sind die, die mit dieser... Ja, du hast darüber getwittert und dieses Live, dieses Sound-Schnitt-Tool.
Genau, das läuft ja hier gerade auf meinem Computer und nimmt diese Sendung auf. Das benutze ich ja immer so als Recording-Tool aus verschiedenen Gründen, die ich jetzt nicht weiter erklären will. Und da ist jetzt für den Sommer die Version 8 angekündigt. Und da sind so ein paar echt coole Sachen drin. Und die machen mich gerade so ein bisschen wirr. Weil ich noch nicht sicher bin, ob es wirklich meine Probleme löst, aber das ist schon cool. Das ist halt ein... Live, muss man sagen, ist wirklich auch so ein bisschen die Definition von Performanta Software. Das ist echt erstaunlich.
Die meinen das ernst mit dem Live?
Jaja, also der Name ist ja Programm.
Also bis eben, bis es gerade sagt, dass es ruckelte.
Ja, hier ruckelt gerade der ganze Rechner. Auch nach diesem Reboot gibt es hier so CPU-Schwankungen. Ja, es ist, ich glaube auch, ich bin mir manchmal auch nicht mehr so sicher, ob es nicht hier vielleicht doch an diesem Rechner liegt. Wie auch immer. Live ist eine Software, mit der man halt, also die eigentlich gemacht ist für Live-Musik und primär ist sie mit die auf repetitiven Schemas beruht. Das ist ja nun in der heutigen populären Musik sehr verbreitet und deswegen ist es eben auch für vieles geeignet, aber es ist jetzt bei Live nicht nur für Techno gedacht, sondern man kann es halt alle möglichen Musik damit machen. Und wie auch immer, diese ganzen Musik, die ganzen Musikneuerungen, die natürlich so der Großteil ist, das kann ich jetzt wieder zusammenfassen und interessiert mich das groß, weil ich benutze das ja nicht für Musik, ich benutze das ja nur, in Anführungsstrichen, für Podcast-Recording. Einfach so wie es aufgebaut ist, super. Und naja, lange Rede kurzer Sinn, die neue Version hat so, kennst du? Nicht für den, als Audio-Software? Max ist kurz gesagt so quasi so ein Audioflow mit Einzelnen, der man zusammenklicken kann. Das heißt, du hast alle deine Module und Filter und schnickest und kannst da einfach so ein Wiring machen, und visuell aufgebaut wird. Das ist immer hübsch. Und dann kannst du das irgendwie programmieren und kannst da alle möglichen Abhängigkeiten machen. So ein bisschen wie Quartz Composer, das so macht mit visuellem Kram.
Ein bisschen so wie es Übercaster vielleicht so andeutet, aber nicht ausführt?
Das ist was anderes.
Also man legt richtig Leitungen durch?
Ja, es geht richtig um darum, den Flow der Musik zu Musikern sehr weit verbreitet. Also bei den Musikern, die jetzt sagen wir mal, sich mehr Mühe machen, als nur so ein Vierteltakt-Rhythmus einzuspielen und dann nimmt man sich ein paar Sounds aus der Library und das war's. Sondern halt für Sounddesigner zum Beispiel. Also Leute, die auch wirklich jetzt auf der Suche nach schrägen Sounds sind. Ich kann das gar nicht genau benennen, weil ich mich da auch nie so richtig eingearbeitet habe. Der Clou ist nur, dass dieses Max jetzt in Live eingebaut wird. Du kannst sozusagen die ganzen super selbst programmierbaren, visuell programmierbaren Instrumente da noch mit reinnehmen. Und das bietet eine Menge Optionen. Meine Hoffnung ist jetzt, das ist nur eine Hoffnung zu diesem Zeitpunkt, weil ich das noch nicht verifizieren konnte. Und es gibt auch derzeit noch keine Version zum austesten, wo das Feature mit drin ist. Es gibt so Early Betas, aber da ist das noch nicht dabei. Meine Hoffnung ist, dass man damit sich halt so ein Custom Interface machen kann, dass man eben so das Podcast-Recording auch vereinfachen kann, was so in meinem Traum von so einem digitalen Podcast-Studio dann ein bisschen näher kommt. Naja, das nur mal so nebenbei. Ist auf jeden Fall eine tolle Software, ist auch eine coole Firma. Und die haben es da echt drauf. Um es mal zu sagen. Also erstaunlich. Ich habe auch ein paar Developer und so ein paar sonstige Leute da kennengelernt. Bin immer wieder erstaunt, was die so für ein kompetentes Team haben.
Ja, was haben wir noch?
Sollen wir noch ein bisschen Werbung machen, Max?
Für das neue 1Block? Für den Podcast? Ja, können wir doch durchaus machen.
Dennis, dürfen wir ein bisschen Werbung machen?
Mach doch.
Hast du unseren neuen Podcast schon gehört?
Ich bin ein Spezialexperte.
Ja, ich weiß. Ich habe nicht damit gerechnet, dass du das mitbekommen hast. Ist auch egal. Wir machen es kurz. Wir schnorcheln Trends.
Und dann Google und alles, was geht und so wie ich. Nein, nicht Google. Nur, dass Low Drone kein Trend ist.
Da bleibt man ja immer so ganz kurz unter der Oberfläche und schaut sich die Fische von oben an. Nicht tauchen.
Nur eine Stunde lang?
Ganz kurz.
Eins Blog, Podcast, Dingsbums.
Null eins.
Geht gerade erst los und ihr wundert euch in einem Jahr, war es schon die 23.
Sendung?
Mal gucken, das ist jetzt erst mal nur auf kurze Zeit geplant. Ich weiß nicht, ob das weitergeht. Das hängt sehr von der Zukunft ab, von diesem Blog.
Ich bin so total stolz drauf. Ich bin stolz wie Bolli, wir waren auf Platz eins in den iTunes Podcast Dingsbums Charts.
Aber das sagt ja wenig aus, wie du weißt.
In iTunes?
Das sagt gar nichts aus.
Na doch, irgendwas sagt schon aus.
Es sagt genau das aus, was wir eben ausgesagt haben. Und das sagt halt nichts aus.
Na ja, aber iTunes ist schon das wichtigste Podcast-Ding-Listening-Programm ever. Für meinen eigenen Podcast.
Egal. Lass mal lieber Dennis ein bisschen featuren hier. Ja, es kamen hier Fragen auf.
Dennis sucht nach Quadrat 840 AV.
Auch irgendwas gehört. Und wenn ich könnte, dürfte ich wahrscheinlich gar nicht.
Aber es ist doch vorgestellt worden, Menschen Skin, das ist doch offiziell.
Wir hatten schon mal darüber geredet, du hast ja diese kleine iPhone-Programmchen geschrieben, den Texta.
Für die Firma Texta. Heißt der Texta, heißt nur Texta.
Die iPhone-Applikation als Interface für diese Webseite texta.com. Die haben jetzt auch ein E-Book rausgebracht.
Schon draußen?
Es ist angekündigt worden. Oder es war ziemlich behalselt.
Ich hab heute irgendwas gelesen, dass die Bilder davon oder wie auch immer nur im Telepolis-Druck in der Print-Ausgabe gezeigt werden dürfen. Also wenn das so ist, dann gibt es noch keine Geräte. Und ich weiß wirklich auch nicht mehr, als da in den News steht. Weil ich hab ja mit der Hardware-Fraktion da nichts zu tun. Ich weiß nur, dass die halt irgendwie ein kodes Zeug am Start haben.
Wir sagen uns mal so ein paar Dinge. Zum Ausprobieren. Und jetzt reißen.
Wir müssen halt mal anfragen.
Naja, das soll auf jeden Fall so ein Gerät sein, so wie dieser Kindle.
Jetzt wissen wir das.
Plus mit dem Vorteil, dass es halt von vornherein im Wesentlichen auf so nicht der im Geschichten beruht, also zumindest offen ist für irgendwie andere Texte.
Und viel schneller ist. Also das, was ich so mitbekommen hab, ist, dass ja auch diese, gibt's ja auch irgendwie so ein Sony-Book-Reader und so weiter, dass die halt so ein Display haben, was halt solange sich nichts ändert, weil so eine Textseite, da ändert sich ja nichts, ist ja nicht, dass da irgendwie schon irgendwie Spam auf dem Schirm ist oder alles sich immer drehen und bewegen muss, sondern es soll ja eine Text sein, total entspannt, dass du den lesen kannst.
Das ist eine E-Ink-Display, was die haben.
Und der Vorteil davon ist und auch Sinn der Sache, ist, dass er halt so gut wie Null Strom verbraucht. Aber wenn du dann halt mit Kunden, oder weiß nicht, vielleicht auch zwei, bis er die nächste Seite aufgebaut hat.
Aber das, ich glaub, das wird einmal komplett schwarz, einmal komplett weiß und dann zeigen sie erst das Bild an.
Das switcht so komisch in so verschiedenen Mustern irgendwie, dauert so eine Weile, bis es so komplett umgeschaltet hat. Und es auch total wenig Strom verbraucht, aber schneller umschaltet.
Aber haben die dann auch so ein E-Ink?
Displäzigkeit nicht.
Ach, da gehste nicht.
Steht irgendwas zum Preis da?
Keine Ahnung. Ich muss zugeben, dass ich den Link nicht wirklich bis zum Ende gelesen habe. Nebenbei auch geklickert. Aber die eigentliche Frage, die dahinter steht, wir können uns da jetzt nicht wirklich kompetent zu äußern zu diesem Produkt, weil das ist irgendwie noch nicht da. Ich hab's noch nicht in der Hand gehabt. Was ich mich bloß frage ist, wie groß ist das Potential von E-Books wirklich?
Ich glaube, E-Books sind einfach nur der feuchte Traum eines Verlegers. Oder nicht der feuchte Traum, sondern die... Ich glaube, das Problem ist eigentlich, dass der Buchhandel hat unglaublich eine Angst davor, dass nämlich dasselbe passiert, was der Plattenindustrie schon passiert ist und was der Filmindustrie passiert wird, nämlich, dass es Raubkopien ohne Ende gibt. Nun gibt es ja von Büchern ein paar Raubkopien, aber so ein richtig großes Ding ist es noch nicht. Und also es ist jetzt noch nicht so wirklich Mainstream. Und ich glaube, die haben Höllen Schiss davor, ihre Inhalte digital anzubieten. Und darum ist Amazon in dem Fall in die Bresche gesprungen, Sony ja auch schon zu einem Zeitpunkt, und sagt, nee guck mal, das ist alles total DRM geschützt. Und damit es nie mit einem Computer in Berührung kommt, haben wir überhaupt. Wenn man eine Chance hat, das irgendwie käuflich anzubieten, probiert man dann die Hardware zu bauen, die natürlich dann wirklich super dazu passt. Also ich meine, dass so ein Ding dann keinen Strom verbraucht, wenn man gerade, also bei diesem Kindle, die Durchlaufzeiten sind ja irgendwie so im Wochenbereich angegeben, die man nicht nachladen braucht. Was ja wirklich toll ist, muss man ja mal sagen. Aber als das kleine Gerät, das ich immer mit mir rumschleppe und einmal 300 Euro dafür ausgebe, wenn ich doch schon ein iPhone an der Tasche habe, was eigentlich ein nicht so viel kleineres Display hat, was dann auch noch Farbe kann. Wie groß ist denn das Display von dem Kindle? Also ich hab mir mal so Fotos angeguckt.
Also von dem Textgerät ist glaube ich mindestens 3-4 mal größer. Mindestens, das ist ja eher noch ein bisschen mehr. Ja, also das Textdateil war schon doch so groß.
Das ist eher so DIN A5, würde ich sagen, ne?
Also das...
Ich weiß nicht, gibt es hier irgendwo eine Beschreibung, wie groß der wirklich ist.
Ich glaube der Vorteil ist halt wirklich, bei diesen Dinger ist, sondern dass es halt so ablesbar ist.
Das ist geil. Ne, also das ist nicht entspannt, das ist hinter das Auge.
Oh, wie schön. Die englische Wikipedia gibt das einem in Zoll an. Wie praktisch.
Und das sind?
Was soll denn die Scheiße? Zoll.
Naja, aber wir wissen doch, wie groß das Display ist.
Wie viele Länder es gibt auf diesem Planeten, die noch offiziell Zoll verwenden?
Sag einfach mal, wie viele Zoll das sind.
Weißt du, wie viele Länder es sind? 3,6 Zoll mal 4,8 Zoll.
3,6 Zoll mal 4,8 Zoll?
Gar nichts.
Da sind auch ein paar Schlaumeier im Chat, das ist unglaublich.
Und so alle von euch, die dran haben.
Wissen ihr auch, wie viele Länder offiziell noch Zoll haben? So, also 3,6 Zoll sind 9,144 e-5 Kilometer.
Liebe Zuhörer, Sie hören live, wie Tim Brittlauf probiert. 9 Zentimeter?
Das ist echt klein. 9,1 Zentimeter?
Auf der längeren Seite?
Mal 12,1.
Also so ein iPhone-Display hat glaube ich einen Durchmesser von 3,5 Zoll?
9 mal 12.
9 mal 12. Das ist...
Mal einfach zu halten.
Die exakten Zahlen interessieren doch jetzt eh nicht.
Ja, also meine Theorie ist, dass das hier mein iPhone-Display ist. Das ist 5 mal...
Das ist ein bisschen mehr als doppelt so groß.
Das ist nicht viel größer.
Das ist ja winzig.
Da ist ja unten noch die Tastatur dran.
Hast du einen von diesen E-Book-Applikationen mal ausprobiert?
Auf dem iPhone?
Ja, benutzt.
Ich hab so richtig benutzt, habe ich leider nie welche. Ich hab das...
Du hast sie runtergeladen.
Ich hab sie runtergeladen, mal ausprobiert so ein bisschen und wirklich was drauf gelesen. Also ich hab mir dieses Classic-Zeichen sogar gekauft, wo man dann so schön mit dem Finger rumblittern kann. Das fand ich mal eine schöne Lösung. Ansonsten fand ich die eher alle so, naja, so halb. Also das muss eigentlich so gehen, dass man unter dem Bett liegt, am besten noch die Decke über den Kopf hat, irgendwo mit dem Finger drauf titscht oder so was. Eine möglichst einfache Bewegung, die auch nicht zu ermüdend ist, wenn man so mit...
Ja, so ein Swipe vor-zurück.
Ja, aber auf jeden Fall mit einer Hand zu bedienen und ohne irgendwelche Probleme.
Das ist bei Classics der Fall.
Das ist bei Classics der Fall. Und da kann ich mir durchaus vorstellen, Buch mal zu lesen.
Ich hab auch mal so einen Abend mit Classics ein bisschen Alice in Wonderland gelesen. Und das fand ich gut. Vor allem fand ich ganz gut, dass der Bildschirm A klein war, weil dadurch hast du so eine kleine Granularität von Text. Das heißt, wenn ich einschlafe, dann weiß ich das Problem, was ich mit Büchern habe.
Und das ist eine Hintergrundbeleuchtung gerade, oder?
Genau, und er hat eine Hintergrundbeleuchtung. Hast du das Original von Alice in Wonderland gelesen oder die Lost Girls von Ellen Moore?
Ist das irgendwie dieselbe Variante mit Sex and Crime? Echt, es gibt so Sex Alice in Wonderland sozusagen?
Es gibt so einen Comic von so einem Typen, der Ellen Moore heißt, über Alice in Wonderland.
Das gibt's dann auf Parabellas.
Dings von...
Und das sind Filme. Auf Blu-Ray.
Wir wollen jetzt nicht über Schmuddelkram. Achso, es geht um Sex. Ja, wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall habe ich das gelesen und ich fand das ganz gut. Und genau der Punkt, den du jetzt gerade aufgebracht hast, fand ich nämlich auch interessant. Ich konnte es halt nachts lesen. Und fand das jetzt auch so okay, so von der Readability her, also keine Ahnung, könnte man vielleicht auch noch besser machen. However, so ein E-Book, da brauchen wir ja nur Licht.
Wie bei so einem normalen Buch auch.
Ja, aber dafür liest es halt noch ziemlich gut, weil man eben, weil es nicht selber beleuchtet ist.
Aber im Dunkeln liest es total scheiße, weil es nicht selber beleuchtet ist.
Im Dunkeln liest es im Dunkeln auch scheiße.
Aber man will ja einen Fortschritt.
iPhone ist sozusagen noch besser als ein Buch.
Also ich hab früher mal auf dem...
Es geht aber auch schon ganz schön auf die Augen. Also beim iPhone liegt es aber jetzt nicht an der Helligkeit, sondern weil es zu klein ist. Also hast du mal einen Film geguckt eine Weile länger, du kriegst wirklich Kopfschmerzen nach so ein paar Minuten.
Ich hab viel geguckt. Auf meinem iPod hab ich irgendwie viel geguckt. Ich hab ganze Serien durchgeschaut auf meinem iPhone. Ja, was ich auf meinem iPhone seltener mache. Aber es liegt vor allem an der Kapazität.
Aber ist das doch eigentlich größer? Also ich hab mal so geguckt, und entweder du haltest es so weit weg, aber es ist ja dann... dann bringt's mir ja nichts. Also würde ich auch schon gerne so gucken.
Das Hauptproblem mit einem scheiß iPhone ist, dass man das nicht halten kann.
Das kommt auch noch dazu.
Ein iPod kann man gut halten und gucken. Ich liebe meinen iPod 5G.
Und...
Leider ist er weg. Ja, ich meine, ich will jetzt nicht wieder mit der Podcast-Leihe anfangen, aber sie haben einfach viele, viele Sachen, die sie beim iPod richtig gemacht haben, beim iPhone einfach noch nicht drin. Allein sowas wie mal eben die Helligkeit wechseln. Das geht nicht mit einem scheiß iPhone.
Und das ist jetzt mit deinen ganzen iPod-Spielen, die du gekauft hast?
Da mangels iPod.
Sind sie flütten? Wahrscheinlich.
Ja, aber ich hab da viel Spaß mit gehabt.
Das heißt, könnten wir die alle mal übertragen lassen und dann können wir auch gleich noch Lodrunner kaufen.
Du kannst ja auch einfach mal so einen Lodrunner kaufen für das iPhone.
Es gibt Lodrunner fürs iPhone? Ach echt?
Kross.
Wieso gibt es das nicht fürs iPhone?
Weiß ich auch nicht. Das gibt es nur für das iPod. Lieger, Lizenz, Typi, von Amerika weltweit oder wie auch immer. Also wenn der dann immer noch Geld verdient, dann hat er wirklich einen goldenen Hit gelandet. Weil er hat damals schon 3 Millionen Lodrunners verkauft und hat von Bruderbund 23% Gewinnbeteiligung ausgehandelt.
Mit einem Spiel.
Und er hat mit ASCII-Grafik angefangen, das Spiel.
Gute Idee und ordentliche Performance zum richtigen Zeitpunkt und was zur Kohle, wa?
Die Tetris-Story ist ja glaube ich ein bisschen trauriger. Da haben die Original-Entwickler gar nichts gebrannt. Nee, aber ich hab also so...
Mittlerweile hat der da auch ein bisschen von profitiert.
Ich hab mal ein komplettes Buch auf dem Nokia 770 gelesen damals. Das hat ein bisschen größeres Display. Das ging sehr gut. Und früher auf dem Palm habe ich Webseiten gelesen. Quasi, also runtergeladene Webseiten. Sehr, sehr viel auch. Das hat auch Spaß gemacht.
Also ich bin mir nicht so sicher, ob diese E-Book-Geschichte genug Drive hat.
Ich glaube E-Books sind total toll auf diesem speziellen Gerät, aber man hat es einfach nie dabei, wenn man gerade mal lesen möchte. Insofern wird das... Ich habe irgendwann mal die schöne Analyse gelesen, ich glaube von Thomas Kniever. Hallo, das perfekte E-Book-Gerät ist schon da. Das nennt sich iPhone. Der ist zu klein. Soweit von der Realität ist das, glaube ich, nicht weg, weil ich kann auch mehrfach umblättern. Und solange es kein Bilderbuch ist... Also damals auf dem Palm, der hatte noch ein kleineres Display. Das waren 160x160 Pixel und das war ja winzig. Und man konnte echt, okay, darauf Bücher lesen. Das war kein Problem.
Na ja, da gibt es natürlich so unterschiedliche Meinungen mit irgendwie, was ist, wenn du in den Urlaub fährst und dann hast du irgendwie keinen Strom und bist am Strand und so. Aber ich weiß auch nicht, ob das nun so reinhaut.
Ich fahre einfach nicht in den Urlaub, wo ich keinen Strom habe.
Na ja, wir werden es sehen. Bisher sind die E-Books keine nennenswerte Revolution. Auch wenn sich der Kindle an ein paar Leute verkauft. Ich habe jetzt hier noch zwei Themen, die ich noch anwerfen wollen würde, wenn ihr nichts mehr habt.
Weg los!
WebKit hat jetzt ein Feature, das heißt CSS-Animation.
Das stimmt ja so nur halb.
Na sagt, das Surf in Safari.
Genau, also WebKit hat dieses Feature ja schon eine ganze Weile, eigentlich zumindest auf dem uns heiß geliebten iPhone und damit auch in einer iPhone-Simulation.
Also das iPhone hatte es schon lange.
Das iPhone-WebKit hatte es schon lange. Jetzt hat es auch das WebKit-Programm, was man sich auf dem Mac runterladen kann, was es bei webkit.org gibt.
Genau, und was ist das?
CSS-Animation ist... Ups, jetzt hab ich vergessen, hier versehentlich... Ich komm einmal in den Schalter und schon kommt eine SMS. Das gibt's nicht. CSS-Animation ist... Man sieht ja auf sehr vielen Webseiten sieht man ja irgendwelche lustigen Animationen, dass man, wenn man irgendwie den Maus rüber bewegt, dass dann irgendwas passiert. Das sind Animationen, soweit versteht das jetzt wahrscheinlich absolut jeder. Und ich erzähl mich gerade komplett in Blödsinn.
Du meinst du sagst so Sachen daran, dass du da rechts wegliegst?
Das wird immer alles per JavaScript gemacht. Und JavaScript ist potenziell natürlich relativ langsam. Und in dem Fall ist es gar nicht mal das JavaScript, was unbedingt so langsam ist, sondern die Animation. Und nun haben ja moderne Grafikkarten, haben OpenGL und weiß der Teufel was. Also hat sich Apple in dem Fall hingesetzt und hat gedacht, Menschenskinder, wir haben noch dieses geile Core-Animation in Mac OS X drinne. Warum machen wir denn nicht sowas auch für Webseiten? Weil auch Webseiten werden immer animierter werden. Und gerade mit unseren tollen Mobilgeräten, die Strom sparen müssen und wo die Grafikkarte sich die meiste Zeit langweilt, während man so eine Webseite darstellt, aber der Prozessor komplett überlastet ist. Lasst uns doch einfach mal CSS erweitern um Animationsmöglichkeiten. Das haben sie schon vor einer ganzen Weile gemacht. Ich glaube, das ist CSS Animations, gibt es im iPhone seit Version 2.0 vom iPhone, von der Software. Und es gibt da so schöne Demoeffekte, wo man einmal so irgendwas animiert per JavaScript hat auf dem iPhone und daneben dann per das gleiche, per CSS Animation. Und natürlich, wie sich das so gehört, JavaScript ruckel, ruckel, ruckel, CSS Animation smooth wie Sau. Und im Wesentlichen funktioniert das Ganze so, man definiert in CSS verschiedene, naja, ich weiß nicht, so wie in Flash früher, falls man das kennt, so Keyframes. Oder also bestimmte Zustände, also zum Beispiel sagt man, jetzt befindet sich dieses Element da und ist in so und so viel Grad gedreht und hat als Hintergrundfarbe blau und dann definiert man den nächsten Zustand und dann ist es eben ein bisschen größer und an einer anderen Position.
Und die Zwischenstufen werden berechnet.
Und die Zwischenstufen werden live berechnet. Genauso wie bei Core Animation, genauso wie bei Flash, genauso wie bei Flash.
Hab ich die schon.
Bisschen kompliziert, weil es bisher auch keine gute Doku gab. Hab da mal ein bisschen auf dem iPhone mit rumgespielt. Es gibt da ganz tolle Sachen, so richtig mit 3D-Animationseffekten, dass man so Menüs hat, die dann so aufklappen und so was. Sieht alles sehr schick aus. Sieht man in der Praxis bisher natürlich relativ selten. Aber jetzt, wo das in WebKit drin ist und dann möglicherweise auch in Safari 4, wird es sicherlich zunehmen. Und das ist eine schöne......
eine schöne Reife, weil letzten Endes ist es ja so, dass das auch alles extrem WebKit spielen kann. So Namen wie Adminus, WebKit, Minus Keyframes.
Na ja, das ist aber... Das definieren die immer so, bevor, also sie probieren das HTML5 Standard rauszumachen. Und...
Also das ist schon Propos für HTML5.
Das ist schon, jetzt wollen sie HTML5 reinhaben. Und das ist, solange es noch nicht offiziell ist, nennen sie es immer so. Das war mit dem Opacity-Element...
Ich frag mich nur, wie groß da die Chancen sind, dass das schon in HTML5... Was hat in HTML5 mit CSS zu tun?
HTML5 definiert weitaus mehr als nur das eigentliche HTML, sondern es definiert auch das ganze Drumherum. Da ist ja auch diese ganzen Audiosachen und sowas, sind ja da auch alle definiert drinnen.
Das bezieht sich ja auch auf HTML, aber CSS bezieht sich ja nicht unbedingt.
Die definieren da... die betrachten einfach alles auf einmal.
Du sagst, das gehört dazu. Ich hab mich noch nicht so wirklich...
Ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass... Ich glaube nicht bei CSS... Oh Gott, jetzt zeig ich mich, weil ich so ein Bett sein will.
Alles notiert.
Du hast es nicht aufgezeichnet, oder? Du hast es nicht aufgezeichnet, oder? Ach so, neben den Animationen gibt es auch noch einfache Transitions. Also CSS Animation ist... sind mehrere Trans... Also Transitions ist dieser eigentliche Übergang zwischen den einzelnen Stadien und anderen tollen Sachen mitmachen.
Also ich sehe bei HTML5 irgendwie... Es tut natürlich vor allem fürs iPhone interessant. Und ich finde eigentlich grundsätzlich die Idee ganz gut. Und man kann auch eine Optimierung machen in JavaScript-Frameworks, die halt wissen, ich bin in einem Webkit-Browser und ich könnte jetzt diesen Effekt einfach durch dieses Element machen und dann ist es irgendwie smooth und es benutzt weniger CPU und ist halt optimiert. Und als Fallback macht man es halt so.
Genau.
Das ist ja in so einem Framework nicht weiter das Problem.
Ja, eben. Also diese Frameworks passen sich ja relativ schnell an. Also es gibt ja in Webkit zum Beispiel auch mittlerweile die Get Element by Selector. Also mal kurz zur Klärung. So ein proberitärer Befehl, der so... Also das ist ganz hübsch an HTML5, dass sie probieren aus der Praxis zu lernen. Also es ist sehr beliebt geworden. Es gibt in HTML gibt es einen Befehl, der heißt Get Element by ID. Jedes Element der Seite kann eine ID haben, eine Identifikation. Und damit kann man sich alle diese Elemente zurückgeben lassen. Oder das eine, das diese ID hat und kann das manipulieren. Nun hat sich aber als praktisch rausgestellt, es gibt ja diese CSS-Selektoren, dass es auch möglich ist, also gib mir doch einfach alle Elemente zurück, die diese und diese CSS-Klasse haben. Und das bietet eigentlich jedes moderne JavaScript-Toolkit an. Mit dem Ergebnis, dass das ein tolles Feature ist, was man ungefähr alle 20 Sekunden nutzt als JavaScript-Entwickler, aber was...
Aber jedes Mal das JavaScript-Toolkit, wenn ich das ganze Element durchmarschieren muss.
Also haben sich, wo denn HTML5 und moderne Safari-Versionen, ich glaube Safari sogar mittlerweile schon, nicht nur WebKit, bieten dann den Befehl, Document Get Element by Selector.
Also im DOM sozusagen.
Im DOM.
Im API, um auf den eigentlichen Document...
Genau, mit dem Ergebnis, dass das Ganze ungefähr 50.000 Mal so schnell ist. Und eine neue Version von zum Beispiel JQuery oder wie die entsprechenden Bibliotheken heißen, macht das irgendwie im Hintergrund für mich, läuft dann eben auf WebKit 1000 Mal schneller und ich bin glücklich als Entwickler und mach mir darum, gar keine Sorgen zu machen.
Genauso wie mit den Animations.
Genauso wird es mit den Animations auch laufen.
Letzter Punkt, was ich hier noch vor die Füße geworfen bekommen habe, ist, wir hatten noch über IPv6 geredet und Airport und so weiter. Es gibt jetzt für diese Fritzbox auch ein Update. Also ein Firmware-Update. Und tatsächlich kommt jetzt diese IPv6-Tunnel-Funktionalität dazu.
Das ist quasi die gleiche Tunnel-Funktion wie bei Airport Extreme auch?
Soweit ich das jetzt aus dem Querlesen rausgenommen habe, im Wesentlichen ist es das ja.
Also man kann sich einen Tunnel damit hochziehen, man kann auf IPv6-Seiten zugreifen, egal ob der Provider das unterstützt oder nicht, aber man kriegt auch keine echte IPv6-IP, oder? Oder hat man damit eine echte IP?
Man hat dann mit diesem Tunnel auch eine richtige IPv6-IP.
Und ich hab jetzt quasi hier auf meinem MacBook Pro gerade eine echte IPv6-IP, mit der ich auch ohne Natural Version und alles von außen erreichbar bin?
Nein, weil...
Jungs, ja, das heißt nicht IPv6-IP, das heißt IPv6-Adresse.
Wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall. Ich weiß nicht, was er meint. Da ich ja diese Connectivity-Probleme hier hatte zu diversen Sites...
Hast du es abgeschaltet?
Wenn ich es selbst eingeschaltet hätte, habe ich da die Funktionalität All-Incoming IPv6-Traffic, weil ich hier definitiv nichts serve.
Also du hast einfach eine Firewall eingeschaltet. Aber es ginge ohne diese blöde Blatt-Untermittlungsfunktion.
Das ist ja sozusagen das Ding bei IPv6. Ich würde sogar sagen, das ist das Ding. Okay. Diese Adressraumbeschränkung ist einfach weg. Es gibt einfach genug Adressen bei Definitionen. Und das bedeutet auch, dass jeder eine vollwertige IP-Adresse erhält. Es gibt zwar auch das Konzept einer lokalen Adresse nach wie vor. Bloß das hängt eben einfach von deinem Router ab. Und diese Tunnelgeschichte ist ja explizit dafür da außen. Genau. Weil IPv6 kann sich lokal auch ohne Router konfigurieren. Also wenn du hier deinen Rechner in so einem Laden aufklappst und es gibt halt keine IPv6-Connectivity, hast du ja trotzdem eine IPv6-Adresse. Und zwar ohne, dass es irgendein Gerät gibt, was dir eine gibt. Weil die Rechner in der Lage sind, sich selbst einzugeben.
Und das basiert im Wesentlichen auf der Mac-Adresse, oder?
Genau. Die nehmen dir einfach die Mac-Adresse und stanzen die in so einen wohldefinierten Prefix rein und dann bist du sozusagen out of the box konnektiert. Das ist das Coole an IPv6. Das ist einfach so für Ad-hoc-Networking ist das einfach darum ist es auch gebaut.
Die HTTP komplett überflüssig mit IPv6, weil da gibt einem der Router die vordere Hälfte von der neuen Adresse und die hintere Hälfte ist die MAC-Adresse, die normale, oder? Die MAC-Adresse ist in der Mitte?
Nee, die wird in die Mitte so eigen geflastert. Aber die haben da keinen DHCP, die haben da so einen anderen Service, aber ist schon ähnlich.
Ja, es gibt nach wie vor eine Adresszuteilung.
Ach, ich dachte das wäre einfach...
Das ist aber Teil des Protokolls. Also das Teil der ganzen IPv6-Geschichte ist das alles wohl definiert und ich kann es jetzt hier nicht mehr runterbeten. Ich hab mich vor x Jahren mal ausführlich damit beschäftigt, aber seitdem IPv6 nicht wirklich weiterverfolgt. Tatsache ist was, in dem Moment, wo dein Router ein IPv6-Tunnel macht über IPv4, brauchst du eben, bist du nicht mehr angewiesen auf einen Provider, der dir IPv6-Connectivity bietet. Auch wenn das jetzt absehbar ist, dass das bald kommt. Also es ist...
Habe ich erzählt, ne?
Hast du erzählt. Also es ist... Ich würde nicht sagen, dass es vor der Tür, aber es gibt Berichte, dass die Armee ein paar Tage von unserer... von unserem Dorf gesichtet wurde in den Bergen.
Die IPv6-Armee?
Die IPv6 ja, die sind die Befreiungsfront, die palästinensische Befreiungsfront. Oder war es die Volksfront für Judea?
Oh Gott, palästinensische Befreiungsfront könnten in heutigen Tagen auch in den falschen Hals kommen, glaube ich. Also aus Brian's Life. Sobald es das klingt dazu.
The Life of Brian.
In diesem Sinne würde ich sagen, always look at the bright side of life. Hoho, der weiß es auch.
Die zweite Hälfte ist besser als die erste. Ich glaube in dem Fall hier, was diesen Podcast angeht, auf jeden Fall.
Was?
Qualität des Podcasts.
Des Films?
Nee, des Podcasts, was diesen Podcast angeht.
Die Truppe, die übrigens den Song singen, bei Life of Brian kommt ja der Song am Ende, das Suicide-Kommando. Das sind übrigens die Nazi in dem Film, das wurde aber rausgeschnitten.
Nochmal.
Welche Truppe, wo was?
Die, die am Ende kommen. Genau, und am Ende, wo er dann irgendwie da am Ast hängt, also am Kreuz. Und dann kommen noch alle und bekunden noch mal ihr Bedauern und wie auch immer. Also alle so. Und dieses Suicide-Kommando kommt doch auch und die bringt sich doch dann um vor ihm oder so. Und singt vor diesen Song.
War das sowieso? Nee, die singt am Kreuz, um das Lied anzusingen.
Ach ja, so war.
Shit.
Jedenfalls dieses Suicide-Kommando, das sind irgendwie so eine Anspielung an Nazis. Und da gibt es auch einen vorderen Teil von. Man sieht eigentlich nicht nur am Ende, aber es wurde irgendwie weggeschnitten.
Wegen Befindlichkeiten.
Stimmt, das ist dieses Selbstmord-Kommando, das taucht theoretisch irgendwo in einem Film noch mal. Die wollen ihm dann auch folgen. Und das ist aber irgendwie rausgeschnitten worden. Und am Ende sieht man nur, dass es eigentlich komplett unpassend ist, dass die da ankommen, ihnen bretten wollen und sich dann einfach alle erstreichen.
Die wollen ihm folgen. Die wollen ihm ja alle folgen. Life of Brian ist eigentlich die erste reale Instanz von Twitter.
Du willst verstehen, was Twitter ist?
Aber ihr seid alle Individuen.
Okay, lass uns die Sandale heben. Haben wir's? Wir haben's, oder? Das haben wir jetzt wieder zusammen gelabert.
Eine Minisache hab ich noch. Und zwar der letzte Snow Leopard Bild. Weil die vorherigen, die liefen ja nur auf den ganz aktuellen irgendwie Max mit 64-Bit. Und jetzt der aktuelle Bild läuft auch auf einem bisschen älteren Rechner in 64-Bit. Und da zeigt der Colonel dann an, dass er irgendwie 16 Exabyte virtuellen Memory verwalten kann.
Das ist voll toll.
Und überhaupt ist bei Snow Leopard alles in 64-Bit.
Ja, das gehört sich auch so.
Bis auf iTunes natürlich.
Das, da bin ich mir übrigens, also, ich weiß nicht, ist es unangemessen zu hoffen?
Dass es stirbt.
Es gibt ein, ich meine, warum haben Sie es noch nicht ersetzt durch was ordentliches? Warum?
Na, weil es viel zu cool ist und viel zu groß. Cool. Na wahrscheinlich sagt die iTunes-Abteilung der restlichen Abteilung, ihr könnt es, ihr verdient dreimal mehr Geld als ihr, ihr habt ja irgendwie gar nichts zu melden.
Wir haben iMovie neu geschrieben.
Ja, aber iMovie, die verdienen noch kein Geld. Das sind doch wie so paar Funtis.
Es ist nicht so, dass es sich nicht um eine unkomplexe Software handelt. Ich meine, wenn ich jetzt iTunes und iMovie miteinander vergleiche, dann ist einfach iMovie komplexer.
iTunes wird eine, oh, wäre ich mir nicht so sicher mit so...
Ich wäre mir auch nicht so sicher. iTunes ist schon echt mehr als alles drinsteckt.
Was ist denn da drin? Also du kannst, du kannst, du kannst, ich hab mir sagen lassen, man kann mit iTunes Musik abspielen. Das soll wohl irgendwo drinstecken.
Oh, das ist ja sehr schwierig.
Nee, das ist, dass, dass, Filme gucken, du hast eine komplette DRM-Verwaltung. Das ist die Introducing Service.
Du musst all die drei Tanks können, alle Versionen, das ist der Wahnsinn.
Du kannst mit jedem iPod seit Generation 1 das da ran und Firmen wir aktualisieren.
Neuschreiben heißt doch nicht, dass sie jedes einzelne...
Das ist schon ein ziemliches Monster.
Neuschreiben müssen, sondern da ist ja ein großes Maß an Reusability. Aber sie sollen einfach diese ganze Carbon-Dependency rausnehmen. Sie sollen einfach mehr von ihren eigenen OS X Sachen benutzen. Und vor allem, ich meine, warum ich jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen Hoffnung habe, dass sich da irgendwas tut. So ein iTunes X, sagen wir's mal so, iTunes X kommt raus, wenn was rauskommt? Ich bin mal sehr gespannt.
Ja, dank einem Cocoa-Finder, können wir jetzt die Filme auch schon im Icon abspielen.
Wirklich? Na, siehst du mal, Performance is coming to the Macintosh.
Aber immer nur einen.
Wenn iTunes sich damit...
Das ist wirklich so eine kleine Kräuter.
Immer nur ein Film.
Das konnte ja damals schon Bio erst besser. Nicht im Icon.
Irgendwas um damals mit diesem...
Aber weißt du, was ich meine?
Warte, warte, warte. Mit diesem Bio-S-Müs, dass man da mehrere Movies gleichzeitig spielen kann. Ich hab das damals gleich mal, bin ich hingegangen zu meinem Mac und hab irgendwie zwei so ne Quicktime-Player gleichzeitig gestartet. Und das war auch gar kein Problem.
Ja, aber damals war Bio-S doch wirklich so weit voraus.
iTunes ist doch nicht in meiner Lage zuverlässig, einen einzigen Film anzuzeigen.
Klar, das ging.
Das ging? 1867.
Und zur gleichen Zeit auf der gleichen Hardware, wo das Bio-S auch lief. Ich hab ja das Bio-S auf meinem PowerPC 7500 gestartet.
Ich hab hier ein Dual-Core-Gerät, das ist glaube ich keine zwei Jahre alt. Und wenn ich hier in iTunes einen Film abspiele und ich schließe parallel ein iPhone an, dann ruckelt der nicht, sondern der hält mehrere Sekunden lang das Abspielen des Films an. Mehrere Male hintereinander, über einen Zeitraum von zwei Minuten. Weil iTunes ist Dreck!
Achso, du spielst in iTunes ab. Eine iTunes kannst du zum Film spielen.
Ich rede die ganze Zeit von iTunes. iTunes ist einfach mal stinkende Scheiße, eine schwärende Wunde, eklige Zumutung.
Willst du damit sagen, du magst iTunes nicht?
Ich hab ja die Befürchtung, dass, wenn sie iTunes neu machen, dass dann ganz viele Features nicht mehr da sind. Also alles, was ich zum Musiktaggen benutze und so, ohne deren Musik zu kaufen, wird wahrscheinlich alles nicht mehr gehen.
Ich glaub nicht, dass das das Problem ist. Das Problem ist Performance. Die Funktionalität von iTunes, die kann man hier und da beklagen. Da ist eine Menge Sachen drin, die wir auch wertschätzen. Aber das Problem ist die Performance. Und wenn sie jetzt sowieso mit QuickTime 10 kommen, warum nicht gleich iTunes 10? Und dann für Windows können sie ja nicht wegen dieser Codebase aufrechterhalten. Da merkt man das eh nicht. Ich meine, iTunes läuft auf Windows eh scheiße. Das passt dann auch zum Betriebssystem. Und auf Macintosh ist iTunes eine Beleidigung. Oder? Ich meine, fühlst du dich nicht beleidigt? Ich fühl mich beleidigt. Ich bin persönlich...
Also ich nutze iTunes nicht so...
Eingeschnappt. Ja. Ich will nicht mehr.
Ich nutze... Ich halt die Luft ein.
I'm done.
Das hält doch eh nicht lange durch. Also ich finde, ich nutze iTunes eher relativ selten. Also ich höre damit ganz, ganz selten meine Musik. Ich synchronisiere im Wesentlichen mein iPhone damit. Und damit finde ich es jetzt nicht ganz so furchtbar schlimm. Ich finde es eigentlich eher furchtbar, dass so viele Funktionalitäten in ein oder andere Programm integriert sind. Und Timo hält tatsächlich immer noch die Luft an. Das ist sagenhaft. Und es wird auch schon ein bisschen rot. Oh Gott, wir hatten heute schon einen Notfall während der Sendung. Sorgt mich noch für den zweiten. Ich würde sagen, bevor es jetzt, bevor Tim jetzt umfällt, sagen wir will ja Tschüss, oder?
Ich gucke gleich mal, ob es top verabgelt.
Genau, gab es noch nicht ein Security Update letztens?
Hey, iTunes X?
Komm, wir gehen jetzt.
Wir gehen, wenn es am schönsten ist.
Tschüss!